e
what
oh I can't say
that
[Laughter]
down see we're having fun already did
you miss me okay oh yeah yeah I know
we'll be swinging in as as we get
going how you doing Mary very well how
are you excellent another beautiful day
in paradise follow through and send you
my notes as much as they are the outline
got screwed up at some point just
because I was TR are we on camera thank
you I have a
pen say again I might need that I think
I
W took me forever to figure that mgu y n
she's that's right Jerry we're waiting
we started a few minutes late in order
to give some people a chance to arrive
um thank you very much for attending uh
my name is Jordan erery I'm the vice
chair of ways and means and I'm opening
this in the absence of our chair who's
attending another meeting which uh I
thought only Senators had two meetings
at the same time but apparently chairman
do two at any rate uh like to begin this
briefing session today and introduce our
first Speaker of the day Jason
Wong uh did I pronounce that
correctly thank you uh yeah and don't
forget push the button the red light
means you're talking no red light means
it's it's a speaker thank you um he's
the senior vice president of strategic
planning and research at the federal
Home Loan Bank of Boston we're going to
talk about the regional economy let's
not talk about Boston they don't know
how to rent
property but thank you very much thank
you very much Mr Vice chair and good
morning um great to be here with you
this morning thank you for the
opportunity to discuss the economy um by
way of introduction the feder bank of
Boston World lender to lenders uh and so
almost all Community Banks most credit
unions and insurance companies in New
Hampshire are members of the federal
Home Loan Bank of Boston and so we we
make loans to uh fund their uh funding
and liquidity needs so it's great to be
here with you this morning um so I'm
going to provide an economic update
focusing on the national economy and uh
Regional economy I was here uh at this
briefing two years ago and when I give
economic presentations I like to focus
on one or two big questions and try to
address them question two years ago was
why is inflation so high so we're seeing
historically High inflation rates in
2022 9% um and we hadn't seen seen that
kind of number in 50 years so the
question was why why was inflation so
high so that was the topic two years ago
and today I'm going to ask the flip side
of that question why is inflation so
much lower between 2% and 3% how do we
bring inflation down that low and what
is the outlook on inflation going
forward that is probably the key issue
that'll determine the stance of monetary
policy going forward and that'll impact
the overall economy as well a question
that follows from asking that question
why is inflation so much lower is um are
we likely to see an economic downturn as
we continue this fight against inflation
that's always the concern you tighten
policies to withdraw stimulus in hopes
of bringing inflation down but the risk
is will that lead to an economic
downturn and adversely impact employment
and uh National output so I'll address
that question as well okay so that's the
topic and
um let's start with this chart here on
inflation um in your handout uh sorry we
lost a color coding here the color
coding is helpful so I'll try to um
point you to uh sort of the key patterns
of the data describe them in words and
I've got my little uh laser pointer here
that you can follow on the uh the screen
as well so when I show these inflation
charts I'm going to start right before
the pandemic to give us a baseline of
what inflation looked like before the
pandemic so that on the horizontal axis
I'm usually starting in late
2019 and then I'll I'll continue that
chart to the most recent data points
which is December 2024 or a little bit
earlier depending on what data was
available as of last
week uh when I show inflation charts uh
I want to keep in mind what the FED is
trying to get us to their target
inflation rate which is 2% so I
represent that with this uh dashed green
line here as you can see on the screen
I'm I'm sort of pointing to it with my
laser pointer that's the that's the
fed's Target and the goal is to bring
inflation to that level uh with monetary
policy I show two measures of inflation
here the blue line is CPI Consumer Price
Index that's commonly referenced in the
popular press and when we talk about
inflation the second measure uh shown in
the red line is the pce or personal
consumption expenditure price index and
that is the index that the FED focuses
on so the red line is what the FED
watches and their goal is to bring that
red line down to 2% a year represented
by the dashed Green Line uh in a
sustainable way that's their goal so how
close are
we we're pretty close we're pretty close
look at the look at the red Dash red
line here the PC inflation and that is
uh the most recent reading of that was
2.4% that's what's shown in the red
line uh the Fest sometimes looks at a
core measure of the pce index which
excludes more the more volatile
components of food and energy so once
you exclude that you're a little bit
higher at
2.7 so 2.4 is shown in this red line
including the full basket of of goods
goods and services and then once you
exclude food and energy sometimes called
core index a little bit higher at
2.7 so overall though when you look at
sort of the full picture here during
2022 we were at very high rates of
inflation we had not seen in 50 years n
9% uh or thereabouts but since then
we've made tremendous tremendous Pro
progress in bringing inflation down and
we're now between 2% and 3% very close
to the feds Target of two but not quite
there yet because the core index is
still coming in a little bit closer to
three than it is to two and that's why
this fight against inflation continues
and that's why there's a continuing
debate about whether to keep interest
rates where they are uh in a somewhat of
a tight monetary policy stance or to
bring rates down because hey it really
feels like we've beaten inflation and
now the concern is on the labor market
side make sure that there's no downturn
there and so maybe we should be raise
lowering rates further so that's the
debate that happens at the fomc so
that's where we find ourselves so I want
to offer a sort of a more of a
perspective on how it is that we've
brought inflation down this much how do
we go from 9% inflation to 2 point
something per inflation that's a an
achievement so how do we get there all
right so when we think about how we did
this it's important to distinguish
between goods and services
consumers spend uh household budgets on
goods and
services and the inflation picture looks
quite different depending on what you
focus on the inflation on Services looks
very different from inflation on Goods
so what's shown here on this chart and
and this is a little busy might be to
see on your hand out here but I'll try
to explain on the screen again the
dashed green line is the target
2% um about 2/3 of household budgets is
spent on Services I'll I'll talk more
about what that means what kinds of
services we spend money on but that's
the majority of our household budget
goes to uh services and the inflation
rate on Services is represented by the
green line here which is this line here
and as you can see the inflation rate on
services
is higher than the fets rate target of
2% and quite a bit higher it's above
5% right now the remaining portion of
our household budget about onethird of
our our budget is spent on Goods goods
are often distinguished between durable
goods uh things that last a long time
and and we purchase them less frequently
versus non-durable Goods things that uh
don't last very long and we purchase
them often like food and so durable
goods are represented by the blue line
which is the bottom line here and that's
the inflation rate of durable goods and
the red line is the inflation rate of
non- durable
goods okay so what do you notice about
Services versus Goods we have a very
different story on inflation depending
on what you're focusing on on
Goods we do not have an inflation
problem on Goods the inflation rate is
either below 2% as you can see here for
non-durable goods in the in the red line
L inflation rate is close to
zero and what you noticed about durable
goods the Blue Line uh representing
inflation of durable goods it's actually
in the negative territory meaning prices
compared to a year ago are falling on
the durable goods
category right we do not have an
inflation problem on goods and really
inflation issue is concentrated in the
services sector as you can see in the
green line being higher than the dash
horiz onal line right so why do we have
this uh a Divergent story here for goods
versus Services that's the crucial thing
to understand when we think about how it
is that we brought inflation down and
then what is the outlook on inflation
going
forward okay so let me start with Goods
tell a story there and then I I'll turn
to Services where the problem is okay so
let's focus on Goods first where the
inflation picture looks pretty favorable
so durable goods
um these are are things that last a long
time and we purchase them uh
infrequently so what what would be the
classic example of durable goods that we
purchase automobiles cars we we buy them
uh I don't know what all your uh car
purchase habits are but in my case it's
a very long time before I purchased a
new car uh and so automobiles are
classic um durable goods it represents a
big uh chunk of the household budget as
well and so I'm representing in the blue
line the inflation rate of new cars and
then in the red line represents
inflation rate of used cars so the new
car market used car market are a little
bit different uh and so the price
movements are represented by the Blue
Line new cars the red line um used cars
and uh the other category of durable
goods that's uh uh important is uh
appliances and these are like household
appliances washing machines dishwashers
uh refrigerators we buy them one and
then we use them for a long time so also
an important category Furniture is
similar as well um and so what do you
noticed about the inflation rate on this
category a very important category
durable goods represents um within the
goods category durables versus non
durables the durables represent the
larger portion uh and so this is an
important category to track some people
think that this is also a leading
indicator of uh economic activity when
folks feel like their job prospects
aren't as good and and there's a risk of
an economic downturn what do folks do
well you start cutting out uh
discretionary spending and also you you
you adjust your spending on durable
goods maybe instead of getting that new
car I'm going to look at a used car
instead uh so the spending patterns
shift and so what happens with durable
goods sometimes is seen as a leading
indicator so an important category to
look at here but what is the inflation
rate what what is the inflation rate
relative to the feds Target of 2% it is
lower for all of these categories here
uh we don't have an inflation problem in
cars anymore we did back in 2022 in a
big way uh as you can see here and this
was a big part of what I presented to
you two years ago when I was asking the
question why why is inflation so high
big part of the story here was on
durable goods especially ones that are
manufactured outside the US having
trouble getting here uh because we had a
major supply chain issues and the lack
of Supply driven by pandemic Rel supply
shortages led to this big run up in
prices and that was a big part of the
inflation story so we talked about that
two years ago that problem is gone uh
and so we do not have that problem and
uh prices on used cars in fact as you
can see here used car prices are shown
in the red line and for the past year
what do you notice the red line is below
the zero horizontal axis which means
that uh used car prices have been
declining over the past year so again we
should be careful here though because
there was such a big increase in price
prices during 2020 to 23 yes we're
seeing a price decrease but the level is
still pretty high if if you go out there
and try to buy a car you that's a lot of
money but what inflation is about
year-over-year changes it's not about
the level it's it's about the changes
over the past year and so that is uh
looking favorable so far and the same is
true on appliances um and if you think
about Appliance prices at Home Depot
consumer uh uh durable goods
those prices are also looking pretty
good in terms of uh being at or below F
Target of
2% okay so good story there so far what
about um non- durables so so within the
goods category which is a third of the
consumer consumption basket we talked
about durable goods which is more than a
half of that the remaining is
non-durable Goods which represent things
like food uh which is the the most
important non-durable consumption
category energy is in there apparel so
these are things that we purchase more
frequently so here the story looks
pretty good um a big thing that got
people's attention during the pandemic
was the very sharp increase in food
prices uh driven by uh shortages um and
there were a commodity price inflation
as well and you can see that in the blue
line here that uh I'm sorry the the red
line here is the inflation of food
prices and you can kind of see very high
levels of inflation in 2022 at 10% or so
but that's come down and it's close to
2% as you can see here in the most
recent data points the red
line if you look at non- durable goods
on everything else except food and
that's represented in the by the Blue
Line you can kind of see here that we
did see a very sharp inflation rates in
2022 but that's come down in 23 and it's
now below 2% and in fact it's in it's in
the negative Territory prices are
falling year-over
year okay so even here we T we looked at
non- durable goods we looked at
non-durables and it seems like we we
don't have an inflation problem we've
beaten the inflation problem here right
so if all we consumed were Automobiles
and um food and uh
clothing uh and so on we will be done
with this on inflation it's time to
lower rates and and let's make sure that
we don't we don't run into an issue with
employment that would be the stance
unfortunately uh the goods category
which which is showing kind of these
favorable patterns here is only a third
of our consumption basket the bulk of
our budget isn't spent on here on on
these types of goods it's on Services
that's where the issue is so let's turn
there now and talk about what's
happening with Services inflation and
and why it is remaining persistent and
what the Outlook might be one one more
thing here before we move on this is a
new index that the New York Federal
Reserve Bank uh Federal Reserve Bank of
New York developed during the pandemic
it's called the global supply chain
pressure Index this is an index
measuring things like how long does it
take to ship a manufactured good from
Europe to the US from China to the US
what is the cost of shipping something
from a manufacturing Hub in China to the
US so they created an index um to track
uh changes in uh these uh uh supply
chain issues and what they're showing is
that during the pandemic in 2022 for
example about here uh we're we're about
four standard deviations away from kind
of historical averages and four standard
deviations away from a mean in a
statistical sense is something that
happens like six times out of 100,000
like you would never expect to see this
happen you You' almost this would almost
never happen and that's how bad how
severe the supply chain issues were
during the pandemic
which is why we had supply issues and
the very sharp increases in the goods
category the manufactured goods uh
substantial portion of which comes to
EXC okay of course yes sir um this is a
global supply chain pressure index
measuring things like the cost of
transporting goods from overseas to the
us as well as the length of time it
takes to ship something from Europe or
China or elsewhere to the us and uh what
is showing is that in 2022 it reached uh
supply chain pressures meaning higher
costs and and longer trans transport
times than we've ever seen uh in in in
the way this this uh uh index is
measured so extreme levels of supply
chain pressures uh that uh resulted from
the pandemic and and that's partly why
uh we saw the issues that we just saw in
do you want to take questions as we go
I'd be glad to yes sir thank you uh well
you've got a peak that is almost as high
and I can't read any of the numbers so
on I presume it's maybe six months
before or a year
before Oh I'm I'm yeah it Peak I AP so
so the uh the the peak here is January
of 2022 the height of the pandemic and
so since then it's been coming down and
this here is uh the horizontal axis here
is is the historical average and so if
you're if you're at this the black
horizontal axis that means you're about
where you've been in the past uh and so
that's where we are today yeah yeah but
I think she uh the ranking member is
asking about uh
2019 ah is that 2019 uh
2019 this is January this is January 20
so the pic has started okay and so right
at the outside of the pandemic we do see
the small Peak here okay so it is
they're both both Peaks are oh yes I
understand yes that's exactly right yeah
yes uh so correct me if I'm wrong but I
think you said in the beginning that
your horizontal line is basically 2019
202 no no no the the the um the
horizontal axis is an historical average
that goes back well before the pandemic
so it represents well what is normal in
a typical economic environment very good
thank
you I just um just related sort of
related to this on on the slides are
difficult to see this one didn't even
manage to reprint oh uh but on would it
be possible for us to get all of these
slides digital absolutely yes uh I I
think the the colors on these charts
have really helped and so I I'll I'll
make sure I'll send these to Jennifer
here so you have you have the full slide
deck Jennifer's already got them yeah
thank you right send them out to anyone
who wants they can contact uh Miss Flor
she has them thank you u a further
question um under durable goods you did
not mention uh uh real estate you know a
third of our budget more or less goes to
either rent or goes toward owning a home
you know we've seen substantial
inflation across the country with you
know affordability of homes where's that
in this calc that's that's in Services
that's in Services yes it is yeah yeah
that's a perfect segue so it's it's
called rent of shelter and rent of
shelter is considered Services category
yeah sorry let's try it again sorry this
isn't a question but thank you for this
chart we have never seen this kind of
chart before of course no thank you okay
so let's let's continue here so uh we
we've covered the the goods category
and uh the the bottom line here is that
things look favorable we don't have an
infl problem but now we'll come to
charts where we have an inflation
problem so let's come to the next uh
chart here which is inflation on
services so as representative just
mentioned a very important Point uh
shelter alone Housing Services represent
a third of the full budget it it's it's
more than half of the services category
60% or higher of the services and a
third of the entirety of of uh household
budgets so as representative mentioned
it's a very important category what
happens to it uh is a very important
factor in determining overall rates of
inflation um in Services the most
important category is housing followed
by Medical Services followed by
transportation services followed by
education so those categories uh
housing uh medical
expenses uh transportation services
including airfare uh and so on and then
um educational tuition including Child
Care th those are the big categories
within Services uh and let's see what's
happening there so in this chart you
have uh the um Red Line representing the
rent of shelter so rent of shelter is
something that captures
um the rent payments if you're a renter
but uh for homeowners you have an Ed
rent for homeowners of course do not pay
rent um they may have mortgage payments
so so there's a lot of Statistics that
goes in to determining what an imputed
rent might be to rent that house that
the homeowner owns what would a market
rent be so there's a kind of a lot of
calculation that happens at the Bureau
of Labor Statistics yes sir so the the
red line would also include uh your
property taxes uh and utilities are
separate util utilities are are separate
utilities are in a separate category um
capture sometimes in energy costs and uh
property taxes that's a great question
um what carry that falls into exactly
I'll have to go back and check um but
that's a that's a good uh question as
well so uh rent of shelter is the red
line and then the blue line here is all
other services so everything else I
mentioned that's in the services
category is captured in the blue line
Okay so so what do you notice about the
inflation rates in those categories
which are kind of the the um you know
60% or more together of our household
budgets what is happening with the rate
of inflation there the horizontal dash
line again is 2% and so as you can see
here we're quite a bit above 2% so this
is where the inflation problem is uh
that the rent of shelter is still
continued to rise at you know 5% or
higher and all other services also
increasing at similar rates and this is
where the inflation problem is yes sir
on the all other services yes have any
of the entities broken them out into the
categories of housing Medical
Transportation okay so we we'll look at
some of that yes it's it's coming right
up yes okay so let's take a look at some
of those details here now let me just
shelter uh there there's because housing
is so important and because housing has
been a big driver of the persistence in
inflation the 2022 big uh spike in
inflation a lot of had to do with you
know car prices and supply chain
challenges as we
discussed but the fact that inflation
persists a lot of it has to do with
housing so a lot of research is going
into figuring out what is happening with
the housing market how does it exactly
impact these inflation
indices and uh one one thing that people
are noticing is the housing component
has a very important lag in impacting
inflation in this sense if you survey
people CPI is based on the household
survey if you survey people hey how much
rent are you paying uh on your apartment
uh you're going to get an answer and
then you can kind of track that over
time but what what does that answer mean
is really important right when you ask
somebody hey how much how much are you
paying in rent that's a price quote
unquote that usually lasts a year or
longer longer right it may not be the
current market price if you if you were
to rent that unit out today you might be
paying a different rate than the person
who answered the survey who signed a you
know a a lease or a contract with the
landlord a year ago two years ago
locking in their rate and so to get a
current market rate on that property you
might need to do something so that's
that's an important question yes yes sir
yeah quick question what's the time
scale on that the chart okay so we're
tracking monthly data here so this is
from
uh Zillow which is a real estate website
uh tracks housing prices and they they
make make available a lot of data so we
we got monthly uh data here uh on
something called observed rent so this
is their attempt at track tracking true
real-time Market rents so instead of
like surveying people to ask hey what
what how much are you paying they're
trying to figure out on on rents on
properties that turned over or new
leases that were signed what is the rent
so that's what this is trying to follow
up please what's the end to endend time
period on that chart okay and sir I'm
this is hard to see January 2021 is the
starting starting point and then the uh
last Point here is November
2024 yes okay so
yes yeah state representative Chris ones
um just a question does this include
only rent or does it also include home
ownership okay this is this is only rent
yes this is being recorded in order for
it to be accurately recorded we got to
remember to use the microphones please
thank you okay one one further question
yes I wanted to add on to that on people
remember that you're supposed to go
through the chair and this is the chair
okay okay so the the the pattern that I
want to uh talk about here is that when
you look at realtime market-based rents
that a website like Zillow is tracking
here and this is showing year over your
changes so you you kind of think it as
as like an inflation rate in uh rent um
for rental units and what it's showing
is that yes there was this big increase
in in uh rent inflation in 2022 so again
uh sorry it's the the horizont x is hard
to read here so the peak here is
occurring in early 2022 and it's been
coming down here and has been plateauing
at below 4% rate uh starting about in
late 2023 all of 2024 coming into 2025
so the point here is that there there
may be some good news that will
eventually be baked into the CPI rent
component because we've seen this big
drop off in rent inflation when you look
at market-based data knowing that CPI is
a lagged indicator that'll eventually
reflect this over time that there may be
some additional good news to come on the
rent component of CPI inflation going
forward
yes however from your own dat data it
seems to indicate
that the um core inflation rate is not
the 2% but it's closer to the 4% good
point good point so even uh the core
inflation is so here the rent component
is closer to four it's like three three
point something percent maybe mid three%
but here the thing to note is that even
before the
pandemic um this this is not showing the
full data here going back before the P
what things were like in the 2010s uh
rent did increase faster than 2% per
year and the overall inflation rate was
still below 2% meaning we we had a good
inflation uh good economic environment
on inflation overall even when housing
itself was increasing a little bit
faster than 2% so uh the I think it'll
help CPI inflation on the rent component
once sort of the market what's happening
in real time with the market R rising at
more moderate levels
is reflected in CPI okay so um there
there may be maybe some good news to
come here but the point remains that
housing inflation is high housing
inflation is more like 5% uh when we're
trying to get to 2% so that continues to
be the the one of the main issues
here if I could we have to always
remember that a lot of people are on
fixed
incomes and that on
it doesn't help them that now it's
getting short uh less uh difficult for
the people who are not on fixed
incomes thank you thank
you thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking my question so could we just back
up one slide to the medical and
transportation or did or are they out of
order oh okay okay because I thought
somehow I miss I think on this one I I
uh had the two in the wrong plac that's
fine I good thank you okay now so having
looked at housing let's come to the
other big categories within Services um
so
Medical Care is a big component and
inflation in medical care uh prices is
shown in the BL line another uh category
is transportation
services and uh that is showing very
high rates of inflation that's in the
red line here and that is showing very
high rates inflation higher than 5% per
year okay so let's start with medical uh
care so this is reflecting medical
insurance rates and then any outof
pocket expenses we pay on Medical
Services uh and that is increasing uh at
higher than uh 2% but pretty
close this category um actually if you
look at this over time even even looking
at what it looked like before the
pandemic before the pandemic it's
showing only a little bit of data here
to the very left of the of the chart
here the gray column represents the the
covid recession in early uh 2020 and so
prior to that is before the pandemic uh
and what you see here is that medical
price uh Medical Services inflation was
higher than the um 2% Target even before
the pandemic and we're actually doing a
little bit better it it's it's
increasing at about 3% a year uh Which
is higher than two but better than what
it was uh before the pandemic so I I
would think of this as we're doing okay
inflation but we have a a bigger issue
here on this other category uh
transportation services inflation is
running at uh close to 7% a year um any
guess as to what this might be here uh
what what what related to car
maintenance and
Automobiles uh do we see going up in
terms of prices a big component is auto
insurance so um I don't know if folks
can relate but my I I my auto insurance
certainly reflects this pattern here uh
I I found that my insurance rates have
been going up quite a bit so after
staying with one career for 10 years uh
I just switched uh this past year um
after looking at some uh doing some
price comparisons okay so so that's uh
another uh driver of uh transportation
services category auto repairs uh uh I
don't know if any of you have had uh
cars repaired recently but the cost of
uh getting getting repairs done has also
gone up quite a bit and that's that's
also a thing that is driving up sort of
Transportation Services
when thanks um isn't
um people were not
flying hardly at all during the
pandemic
and a lot of planes were put away in the
Arizona desert because they didn't need
them and then everybody came back and
the planes were
needed needed repairs and things like
that I was wondering um certainly now
every single plane I
I take which isn't very often are uh is
completely full every single seat um
right and so uh that's interesting
observation there uh airfare was a big
component of inflation in 2020 also so
this is when I think what representative
is is talking about is sometimes called
Revenge travel folks being under
lockdown for two years and then all
their plans got canceled
and then when things opened back up uh
so many of us wanted to travel uh and
there was a huge demand surge in demand
for uh air travel and there was a big
increase in airf fars and that was part
of the story of 2022 inflation uh but
what they saying is that that component
it has definitely moderated uh we're not
seeing that not nearly to the same
extent though overall as a category this
is an issue we we have an inflation
issue here uh in in this category of
services Mr
yes if I may um thank you for taking I I
actually have two quick questions and
just um in terms of auto repairs the
component having just gone through this
the component is parts and labor is this
is this does this include labor cost or
is that calculated elsewhere okay so
that that's a very um interesting and
important observation because this
includes uh auto repair costs would
include labor as well as well as parts
and uh perhaps this is what the question
is getting at is what distinguishes
services from Goods what what's the
primary distinction there is that wages
are a much bigger component of services
uh industry as as an input cost than it
is in Goods often in Goods it's the cost
of of uh materials cost of things that
you purchase from somewhere else to make
something whereas in Services you're not
really importing anything here and the
big component is Wages of your employees
and that is something that we we're
seeing some uh inflationary pressures so
that's a good observation follow up um
the other thing I and I just noticed on
the chart um probably because I didn't
have my reading glasses on um it says
these are the Consumer Price Index for
all Urban consumers yes um we're not a
very Urban state so is there a is there
a difference is is there an
applicability to this that's a good
question so all of the data on CPI will
say us City averages at the end and
because the CPI is meant to be an urban
price index now when uh the labor
department a Bureau of Labor Statistics
constructs this index they they say they
capture 93% of the US population because
cities include very small cities uh but
it does leave out uh like Farm
households and very rural areas and
their surveys don't reach uh those areas
so the this this is an urban Price Index
States okay so that that was my last
last slide on uh inflation here and I
think we spent a good amount of time on
this which I think is appropriate given
how important this is so the story here
is we're very close to meeting the fetch
Target of 2% we're in The Last Mile
we're at 2.7 I think they're committed
to bringing it all the way down to two
how long that takes how quickly it takes
that's the question here we've gotten
there on Goods we don't have the supply
issues that cause the problem on in the
goods category we do have remaining
persistent inflation in services and I
think there maybe some good news to come
on housing uh but wages being a key
category will be very important to watch
as we think about inflation yes um
before we leave inflation and we are
running a little bit short on time um
but before we we'll leave that uh
there's an effect of the M2 U monetary 2
number which kind of keeps inflation or
devalues the dollar whichever way you
want to take a look at it
um plus we were up high prices went up
high but then your inflation which is a
month-to-month increase doesn't take
into consideration that that's an number
above the previous month's value which
was already artificially High because of
the previe two months previous inflation
value how do we get the price is back
down low okay I I don't know that they
will so so this this is a important
question um the fet's target is low and
moderate inflation not bringing prices
back to where they were before the
pandemic so uh If the Fed achieves its
goal which is a moderate level of 2%
inflation year-over-year prices will
always continue to increase and they'll
increase from the current levels as you
as you knowe yes we did have this big
big run up in prices as you see in some
categories we've actually seen a little
bit of a reversal like in car prices
we've seen a little bit of reversal
there so they went a little bit in the
direction of uh going back to what they
were but not fully we're not undoing the
40% inflation that we had in used car
prices fully we're we're undoing a
little bit of that uh so my expectation
would be that if we get to fetch Target
we'll we're going to have moderate
levels inflation but the price levels I
don't think will return to where they
were
if you don't mind our Senators have a
couple of questions of course I tend to
Senators my question about the
applicability
to tax so
okay good question um when I think about
the New England economy specifically uh
my starting point is that National
economy is the biggest Factor we we are
a small part of the national economy uh
5 to 7% % depending on how you measure
it um and what happens to the United
States as a whole will really impact us
so I always start from there um the
things that are more U pertinent or
unique to US housing is a big factor uh
housing prices uh are appreciating here
faster they have historically than
elsewhere in the country and so I watch
housing prices carefully and I think
they're even as housing prices are
decreasing in some parts of the country
now uh that's not what's happening here
I don't think so so the housing market
um continues to be strong and uh will
contribute I think if you were to kind
of isolate inflation to our area that'll
be that's an important factor for the
whole country but probably more
important for us just given how uh
strongly how house prices have increased
uh as you noted there
um and then in terms of uh indust
specific industry impacts um that's a
horror question and I think I my
starting point again is that we are
going to be very sensitive to the
National economy how it does so I I I
start there and then uh I think we'll be
impacted by so overall rates of economic
expansion okay Senator Rosal did you
have a follow thank you um question very
good thank you Mr CH thanks for taking
my question so uh when we're talking
about you're talking about the
automobile and services and so I just
put new tires on uh my Subaru and I was
shocked at what the tire prices were so
might we see a big correction as you
know we're I'm noticing fuel prices are
dropping uh I know during the pandemic
like the heat your home fuel oil prices
are up around five and a half close to
$6 a gallon price of gas I think got
close to five here as well over seven
out west and uh the other day like at
Sam's was like 270 something so it's
really come down so do you do you see
that helping us correct in these
situations or yes I I I think so so
Energy prices are actually a category
that exactly fits uh Mr Vice chair's uh
sort of question earlier which is are
there categories where prices actually
are not just moderating in terms of
inflation rates year-over-year changes
but actually go back to where they were
uh and energy might be one place where
that could potentially happen where uh
because Energy prices reflect sort of
global supply and demand and uh oil
prices um not quite as low as as we've
seen during the very low uh uh price
periods of in Energy prices but they
have they have come down um and so that
that's an area where we've seen
improvements in gas prices as as you
noted uh and other industries that use
uh you know energy as an input will will
will reflect that in in their pricing
decisions as well so I think that's a
that's another area where uh it's a
favorable factor uh in uh the inflation
Hampshire
yes demographic trend that's going to
make
risk of needing Health
really yeah what what the question is
getting at is that different
consumers uh have different consumption
baskets depending on uh where you live
depending on how old you are uh and I
think the Cent question is for the older
demographic you you what you what your
consumption basket looks like may have
different weights it could be a higher
weight on medical services for example
and so if there's an inflation there
it'll impact you disproportionately
compared to sort of the average US
household may maybe the you know the
weight there on average is 7% uh but it
might be a lot higher than that for uh
an older household and they'll
experience the impact of that uh uh much
more so good point um I don't have the
specific data on specific areas within
New Hampshire but economists do look at
this that the distributional impacts of
inflation differ depending on who you
are and what the household looks like um
and obviously if your consumption is
concentrated in areas that have high
rates of inflation and if your income if
you live on fixed income for example
you'll experience that much more acutely
than than someone else might so that's
that's a that's a good point yes thank
you very much I think we should probably
move on to the next yes and uh if we
could hold our questions until the
entire presentation on employment okay
so Mr Vice CH just doing a a time check
here uh perhaps I could shorten the rest
of my remarks and I I'll try to finish
by uh 10
o'clock okay sounds great um so I'm I'm
going to uh keep the rest of this
relatively brief here and maybe get us
to projections um that you might be
interested in um I have a number of data
on related to employment in the labor
market I think you heard a very good
presentation on this yesterday from uh
the state uh economists so I think I can
keep my remarks brief there and I I
think what I noticed there is two
things uh that the levels and the trends
tell us a different story unemployment
the levels look great if you look at
unemployment
rates if you look at some other data
that's shown in uh my presentation here
the levels look fine we we're still at
very low unemployment rates maybe I'll
just kind of take us to a slide here so
this a slide showing unemployment rates
for the us as a whole and for each of
the New England states a year ago and
what it is now and what it shows is that
um the levels look good New Hampshire
has an unemployment rate of 2.5% very
low um and new hampsh Vermont have had
very low unemployment rates
um and uh we look good compared to the
rest of the country rest of the country
has a 4.1% unemployment rate uh on
average we lower than that so the levels
tell generally a positive story here but
if you look at Trends there are some
trends that are worth watching for
example the biggest economy in New
England Massachusetts we've seen
unemployment rate go up from 3.3 a very
low unemployment rate to 4.0 4.0 is a
good unemployment rate I would say is
still low compared to historical um
experiences but we've seen an uptick so
that does make you wonder okay what is
the trend here and is there anything to
kind of worry about and that's the kind
of discussion that happens at the uh uh
when the Federal Reserve meets to decide
their uh monetary policy is that the
levels look favorable but are there kind
of signs that uh we should watch and
that could potentially be a source for
concern Let Me Maybe show one chart that
kind of captures that um here here's one
chart here it's on job postings so
there's a website called indeed.com this
is one of many sort of job posting
websites and you go there and look for
uh what what jobs available and they
have constructed this index uh this
index is is a the Baseline is 100 and
that's where that's based on how many
job postings there were in the US uh
that's the blue line and um
Massachusetts is in the red line and New
Hampshire is in the green line and so if
you're at 100 that means uh 100 is here
this is the horizontal line I'm sorry
this is really hard to see if you're
there that's a starting point you're at
the same level as job postings there
were before the pandemic in February
2020 and if you're above that 100 line
then uh you have more job postings that
than there were right before the
pandemic and if you fall below then uh
you have fewer job postings and what
this shows is that in 2022 remember when
when the labor market was extremely hot
everybody was looking for workers we had
something like 50 to 60% higher job
postings in the US compared to what we
had before the pandemic that's what this
shows here now what about now so what
you see here is that we've seen since
that peak in 20122 we've seen a downward
Trend the number of job
postings has been declining even though
the level of it looks good if the level
is above uh where we were before the
pandemic the 100 line here so as long as
you're above that you still have more
jobs more companies looking for workers
than we had before the pandemic when we
thought the labor market is really good
you know in right January of 2020 we
thought that was a good economy people
looking for workers uh and what you see
here is that the levels look okay for
the US in the BL line New Hampshire
looks better uh more job postings now
than we had before the pandemic but what
about the trend the trend here is what
is starting to worry some people here is
that this is a downward Trend companies
are recruiting fewel workers even though
the level is relatively high it's not
where we were a year ago or two years
ago in terms of recruiting efforts being
made and number of job vacancies being
filled um Massachusetts is interesting
because Massachusetts represented by the
red line here were below the 100
uh Baseline which is this horizontal
line here and we're below that New
Hampshire's above massach below meaning
we have fewer job postings in
Massachusetts now than we did right
before the pandemic okay so that makes
me as a as a massachusett resident here
thinking about our local economy that is
definitely something that I would want
to watch here um are we starting to see
some weakening in the label Market uh
reflected in this in this trend so the
the story there uh the way I summarize
it is the levels look good we still have
a strong labor market which is why uh
the
um uh strong labor market but the trends
what's happening over the past year and
and if if we extrapolate into the next
year that's where there's a little bit
of a concern uh and that's reflected in
the fact that you know the FED has this
active debate you know should we keep
lowering rates because there are some
softening signs in the label market and
so we should preemptively uh try and try
and make sure that there there's 's not
too much tightening in the in in mon
policy so lower rates or on the other
hand the other side people who are more
hawkish might say look inflation is not
all the way down to two and we're seeing
some persistence in Services sectors and
therefore rates should stay a higher a
little longer so that's kind of the
debate that you see playing out uh at
the FED one more minute on projections
and then I'll conclude here and these
are my final uh
slides uh
these are kind of the most recent
forecasts that I was able to uh access
so this is now a little bit dated from
November 2024 here but survey of
professional
forecasters uh telling us what they
think inflation will be and unemployment
rate and GP growth will be in 2025 and
2026 a quick remark here uh people use
the word soft Landing uh to talk about a
scenario where we bring inflation rate
all the way down to the fetch Target
without triggering a recession so the
economy stays robust employ employment
stays strong and yet inflation comes all
the way back down to the fetch Target
which would be I think if if we're able
to achieve that it would be remarkable
um we that we bring inflation down from
9% to 2% with no without paying an
economic price without causing an
adverse outcome would be uh I think um
an achieve achievement and most most
economists think well that's what'll
happen like look at this we're we're
going to have 2% inflation maybe 2.2
2.1 uh and unemployment rate is going to
stay in low 4% range and GDP is going to
keep growing at above 2% this is a soft
Landing scenario and I think this just
tells you how close we are to getting
inflation back down to 2% the fed's
Target and and the unemployment rate the
employment picture as we just discussed
looks good are there some trends that
are potentially a cause for concern yes
there are we talked about some of that
just now but the levels are still good
unemployment is still low and so
projecting this out to this year and
next year General consensus is that
we're looking at a soloft landing
scenario I certainly hope this this is
what happens here uh and uh that seems
to be sort of the where the consensus is
uh the risk is the the trends identified
are there going to be some worse Trends
in the label Market that we should watch
uh as as this fight against inflation
continues so that's where the kind of
the risk
is thank you very much I've got two
quick questions
on on what you just presented yes the
first is on the um quit rate which seems
to indicate that the gig economy is
decreasing and job stability is in
increasing is that an accurate analysis
actually that that that is a little bit
different than how economists would
interpret this data so quick word here
quit rate is a number of people who are
voluntarily departing from their
employment as a fraction of total
employment so and and the higher this
number is we think the stronger the
labor market is this is voluntary
departure from employment and so the
stronger the labor market the better the
job prospects and the more people are
willing to switch I'm going to leave my
current work here because I'm going to
get a better offer 20% raise I'm going
to take that job and people are willing
to do that more when the job prospects
are better and the economy is doing
better the fact that this is decreasing
in fact it's decreased quite a bit we're
below the quit rate we had before the
pandemic it's a source of concern that
people are less willing to leave their
jobs why what are they worried about are
are their prospects not as good as they
used to be that that's that's the uh
that the economist think about this this
data the other question I had before
representative uh um Edwards has a
question
um when you you're talk about the tax
rate in
Massachusetts and the U profitability of
their businesses with New Hampshire
beating Massachusetts and that is that
related to the tax rate or is there any
analysis on the the business tax uh
environment and the two competiting uh
competing states uh okay so so the the
quick reference that I didn't cover here
to business taxes I was talking about
the federal legislation I was talking
about what might happen with the
incoming Administration I think there
high priority is to extend the tax cuts
that were uh in the 2017 tax cups and
jobs act I think their high priority is
to extend that going forward uh so that
that's an important factor as we think
about economic Outlook and inflation
even so that that's what I focused on on
there and one more question from
representative
Ed thank thank you representative uh um
I my committee often is confronted with
the challenge of um folks coming in
saying they have program issues due to
the lack of Workforce
availability and and and we have some
very dull tools that we can apply uh
from government's perspective uh the key
tool is to suggest that we are able to
um add more money to their budget so
that they can increase their wages in
the hope of pulling out the employment
they need but uh as we do that I I I I'm
always conflicted by the idea that our
Workforce shortages are across the board
you know we don't have uh in my
perception some pool of laborers that
can be changed over to go fit another
part of the economy and so I worry when
we put more money into the wage bucket
really we're not pulling out more labor
we're really just creating a more
inflationary situation so so all of that
is a very long way to to around to my
question which is I I I really could use
some more uh data around these kinds of
Workforce decisions and and I'm just
curious in your experience do you think
data would exist that would help us make
those decisions on yes or no will more
money for higher salaries have a
positive influence in this
micro sector of the economy and what
kind of implications does it have for
the macro if we're just pulling Peter to
go do another
job okay so uh good good question there
I think that is is a long-standing issue
in much of New England especially New
Hampshire perhaps uh my my starting
point in in that thought is yes as you
were saying you might be able to do
something targeting one industry but
there there's a sort of deeper issue
here which which is number of people in
the state um and that has to do with
sort of deeper issues like immigration
rates which I think you discussed
yesterday uh birth rates in the State uh
you know people staying after college
and so on so those are the the basic
issues in my mind that'll determine sort
of how uh employers are able to attract
workers over the long term what specific
policies will do um I don't have data on
that whe whether targeting specific
Industries with subsidies or or wage
support will uh what that will do and
and how that might impact other
industries that lose workers that's an
interesting question that uh I I present
One update on one last question
representative and please give your name
and use the
microphone thank you Mr chair and uh
thank you for taking my question um what
do you see the impact be of the proposed
tariffs on the indicators and inflation
that you presented okay so
um short-term impacts and medium impacts
I I would think that if the tariffs were
to go into effect as have been mentioned
for example something like 60% uh on
everything from China uh 25% on
everything from Canada and Mexico and
then 10 to 15% on everything else from
all other countries
um I so again so so with the comment
that there are a lot of considerations
going into tariff policy not purely
economic I think geopolitical and other
things are also part of the story there
as well but I would expect them to be
inflationary I I would expect that uh
some of the tariffs will have to be
passed on to consumers in the form of
higher prices uh and now
the other side supporting TPS might say
well we're going to raise all these
revenues and we got all these revenues
and they might uh be able to do things
with the revenues that could offset some
of the impact perhaps that's true um I
don't expect that offset to be full I
think the impact of higher prices will
be felt by consumers to what degree
exactly depends a little bit on how much
revenue is raised and what you do with
it but I would expect that on that it'll
be a a positive factor on inflation
which is uh something that the FED uh
the FC is watching the FED is watching
this because if this does go into effect
uh it could complicate their inflation
picture quite a bit so we'll see kind of
what happens
there all right do you have anything
else sir that is all I have thank you
very much Mr chair no thank you for your
presentation it was clear and a reminder
that uh the members of the committee can
get the oh I got one more question yes
sir than you could you use the
microphone over here sir and identify
yourself hi representative Rich Neno
from elstead one of the things that has
bothered me with all of the economic
projections that we've seen is how does
the impact of uh immigration illegal and
otherwise which numbers that range
anywhere from you know 5 million to 12
million some spectacular numbers impact
all of these uh projections and I look
at Massachusetts and some of the numbers
there and say it's got to be some some
impacts in what we're looking at in the
numbers how are they factored in to all
of these
projections um thank you yeah
immigration certainly impacts number of
workers we have and that that's the
primary channel in which I think
um in terms of things like u in
inflation I think there are uh places
where if there's a dramatic increase in
the number of uh you know population uh
growth that happens in a localized area
how that impacts housing prices for
example and other things could be
something that uh people look at I think
in places outside the US for example
Canada in some places in Canada certain
cities have seen big inflow inflows of
immigration that that have uh led to
dramatic uh changes in housing prices
for example uh you know some major
cities in Canada I think have
experienced that uh I'm not sure about
sort of how big that impact is in some
of the numbers that are baked in here
this is at a sort of national level uh
and so um I think uh it's a hard sort of
tease out what the what the impact is
from immigration versus other factors
but I'll just leave it at kind of the
higher level comment there again thank
you very much for your presentation and
thank you very much thanks you for
having
thank you Mr Vice chair good job and um
we will now move on
to Michael Skelton and natch
Grace um from the New Hampshire business
morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh Mike Skelton I'm the
president CEO of the business and
industry Association of New Hampshire um
my role this morning is just to welcome
you and thank you for the opportunity
and then I'm going to hand it over to my
colleague n Grace who's our vice
president of public policy who's going
to share with you some information and
data and commentary on our perspective
on economic conditions here in New
Hampshire um we're very pleased to have
Nate join us in the last month uh known
to uh many of you from his past work um
he's going to be leading our policy team
at the Bia so we're excited to have him
um I just wanted to share uh at the at
the outset of the conversation we've
really appreciated the opportunity to
come in speak with you at these
briefings over the past several years as
an opportunity for us to share what
we're hearing from our members across
the state by way of background uh the
Bia serves as New Hampshire's Statewide
Chamber of Commerce and state
manufacturing association we represent
more than 400 employer members across
the state from all industry sectors of
all business business sizes those
members collectively employ more than
100,000 uh individuals and contribute
more than 5 billion to our state's
economy we also work very closely with a
network of more than 40 local and
Regional Chambers of Commerce and dozens
of Industry trade associations
representing uh all facets of our
economy um so we hear a lot from our
members and stakeholders about economic
conditions and we work hard to translate
and provide you with input and insight
into what that means and how we can make
policy gains to support the growth of
our economy um I don't want to get into
too much detail I've been known to steal
the Thunder of people that I'm
introducing so I don't want to do that
to n because I know he's got a lot of
compelling information to share but I'll
just say I think the the trends that
we've spoken about in the last few years
remain uh very similar to what you're
going to hear today overall New
Hampshire's economy is performing quite
well and quite strong especially
compared to our neighbors in the
Northeast we do have some significant
challenges however and I think what
you'll hear from n and what you've
already heard from other speakers and
will hear from others that pain points
around Workforce availability housing
Supply child care and our regulatory
environment are all issues that are
important for us to keep an eye on to
work on and to ensure that New Hampshire
uh remains economically
competitive and I did want to preview
that some of the data that's being
shared today is being pulled from a new
report that the Bia will be issuing over
the next month called blueprint New
Hampshire 2030 it's an economic
competitiveness report that the Bia
commissioned uh utilizing a consultant
that works with our peer organizations
other state Chambers around the country
and provides us with a overview of
economic competitiveness of New
Hampshire compared to every other state
in the country so a really objective
datadriven view of how we're competing
as a business climate compared to every
other state in the country so you'll get
a snapshot of that today um but we have
more detail coming soon and we would
pause it as an organization that that
comparison of State to- State business
climate in terms of competitiveness is
really the best way for us to approach
these important issues and challenges
how can we compete compared to not only
the states around us but states around
the country on these important business
climate metrics so with that thank you
again for the opportunity and invitation
I'm going to turn over to my colleague N
I will say though if you have any
questions or things that we can do to
work with you please always feel free to
reach out to myself n or our other
you thank you Mike and uh thank you
committee members for uh having us here
today we really appreciate the
opportunity to give our perspective on
uh new hampsh economy both now and kind
of what we see over the next bium and
into the
future um as Mike mentioned we represent
uh 400 plus uh member companies who
employ over 100,000 people across the
state of New Hampshire contributing more
than 5 billion to the New Hampshire
economy um and really one of our focuses
our Prime focuses is uh the economic
competitiveness of New Hampshire we look
not only at a lot of the data that
you've already seen um you'll see some
of that in my presentation again today
um but we also are very interested in um
in looking at five and 10 years down the
road and what's the economy going to
look at what are our members saying are
pain points for them and I don't think
anything that I'm going to cover today
is going to be surprising to you you're
going to hear uh Workforce availability
you're going to hear about how that's
connected to housing uh you're going to
hear how that's connected to child care
uh and and an aging um
Workforce um so I do want to begin with
uh a uh survey of Business Leaders that
we did uh back in I believe it was
September or St A's did on behalf of us
um we uh this was prior to the general
election
um obviously some of the focus has
changed based on uh changes in
administration changes in uh federal
policy you've heard that from uh number
of speakers already um but as Mike said
we we do expect and our in employers
across the state expect to uh to grow
business or business to remain stable
throughout this coming year um they plan
on hiring more employees over 59% said
they were planning on some sort of
growth and when we ask them to identify
their top priorities 86% identified
housing as a top priority um 68%
identified child care as the next uh
difficulty there are obviously ongoing
concerns you've heard from us over the
years on things like energy costs
Healthcare cost C and other costs that
um that businesses have
faced uh overall uh we are According to
some rankings sixth in the overall
business tax climate uh that's an
improvement from 2014 when we were at
8th um you see that uh reflected in
terms of you know how we end up in our
competitiveness um and uh what ends up
happening or our hope is that New
Hampshire becomes more attractive for
businesses to relocate especially from
the surrounding New England um we've
seen that in the news over the past
couple weeks um uh at least one large
business has has relocated and we're
certainly hopeful to continue that Trend
um and make uh or keep New Hampshire as
competitive as it is uh and make it more
competitive
um we also uh you know I think it's
really important to look at um
population growth uh both across the
United United States as well as the New
England area um we've seen a higher
population growth in New Hampshire since
2020 other than in Maine Maine has
attracted uh a large uh number of uh new
um people from across the United States
internationally um and uh what we've
seen is that's different than
Massachusetts we've seen a lot of
migration out of Massachusetts to New
Hampshire that's pretty traditional
um but we've also been attractive to
people from other states that have shed
uh shed uh residents as well places like
California um uh places like uh the
Midwest a lot of them have looked at New
Hampshire relocated to us over the past
uh few years um and we we've seen a
little bit of a shift in where those
imig immigrants are coming from
traditionally we've been attractive to
other New England states more populous
New England states um but we've seen
that shift to more of a national Focus
uh over the past um half a decade or so
um proportionately we've seen more
people in the 30 to 44 uh year age uh as
well as 60 plus um uh since
2020 um we uh obviously one of the
focuses of businesses is to attract the
prime working age so we're we're we're
talking here really 20 to 55 um so we're
happy to see the shift um we're seeing
more people in that 30 to 44 uh age
group um and
that additional availability of prime
working age has made it possible for
businesses to hire more people um and
hire more people within that that age
rank so we are currently 13th on prime
age population um
uh by state that's higher than uh the
average which is 1.4 uh% ours uh our
change was 3.2% so we are attracting a
higher proportion of prime age worker or
prime age individuals working age
individuals than um most other states at
this point in time um we have looked at
some of the projected distribution of
populations to 2050 um one of the
interesting things here uh that we've
seen
is that sort of unsurprisingly uh
Southeastern New Hampshire is likely to
see the largest population growth um
with 240 expected to be the peak
population numbers with a sort of uneven
loss following um in traditionally rural
counties we're talking about Coos County
uh Sullivan County uh we're likely to
see uh continued population uh loss
based on what uh we've seen
traditionally um and we've seen growth
uh in Hills bro Rockingham and marac in
particular um although uh up to sort of
the Conway area um we have some good
data that that's attracting a number of
new migrants as well um we've already I
think you've already seen from others uh
so I won't really I won't go into it but
you've seen from others that um we do
have a a declining uh birth rate here so
our population growth is really
dependent on uh migration from
elsewhere in terms of business
formations uh since 2020 um we are
ranking 18th uh we've had uh six
62.6% increase in building uh uh in
business formations now I want to note
uh just for the record here that there
are some states like Delaware that have
traditionally been the source of
business formations but they don't
actually have workers off in the
headquarters of Delaware but um
realistically all the workers are in
other states um so uh that's just
something I want to flag here because
what we see in New Hampshire is that
often when businesses are formed here we
actually have employees here we have
people running those
companies um and that's that just speaks
workability in terms of uh Advanced
industry jobs uh we've seen a pretty
significant growth um that has occurred
uh in uh various States um throughout
the nation um we've seen a 10.3% gain in
advanced industry jobs uh compared to an
average of 9.4% uh
Nationwide only Maine and Rhode Island
outrank Us in the New England area um so
as industry is looking at places to come
um one of the things we see as a trend
generally is if you have um uh industry
startups uh new ideas coming out of uh
one state um you get Innovative
individuals coming here they think of
their own ideas they form their own
companies um and Branch out um so we're
really focused on keeping that um
competitive Advantage as well uh we are
we are 15th in the tech industry growth
since 2018 and we've seen a 14.5%
increase in jobs uh as compared to a
12.88% um average Nationwide um
unsurprisingly you'll see the
traditional Tech heavy States um as well
as uh some of their surrounding states
have attracted a higher uh percentage of
growth than we have uh so um you know
Nevada uh is one of the ones that is
really um seen a lot of migration from
California for instance um and so we're
really focused on uh New England growth
uh we're happy to happy to see that we
are among the most competitive in New
England for that um certainly we have a
number of sort of feeder uh universities
uh to the south of us um that really
promote a lot of that we're happy that
the uh graduates from those universities
want to stay in the New England area and
that they chose choose New Hampshire to
come and and uh and support our burining
tech
industry in terms of innovation scores
uh we are 11th best
um uh but uh much of New England as well
as New York are also in the highest
third um so I just want to point that
out as
well um one of the things that is of a
bit of a concern is our GDP per capita
is below the national average of
$66,872
uh 86 um so we're not far behind the
national average um but that is
something of concern um that we just
wanted to
note um and I just wanted to give you a
little bit more detail here of US versus
uh Nationwide uh and that change of uh
per capita growth um United States
overall 88.7% New Hampshire 8% uh since
2018 um obviously with the
um recession that occurred briefly in uh
2020 uh our hope is that uh the economy
would accelerate a bit more than it has
um but that being said we are in a
strong economic position um we
anticipate continued growth uh we
anticipate that New Hampshire has
advantages that other states do not have
uh and just to mention uh or give you I
guess kind of an overall picture of our
economy we have a very Diversified
economy um so manufacturing is about 10%
uh that's the small uh kind of red
sliver the top right hand uh that's 10%
of our employment in the state and you
can see we have a pretty Diversified
economy we're not focused overly in one
area um that being said we do have some
um some areas of State support that
really um focus a lot of our economy so
for example travel and tourism is very
important uh to both our our members as
well as uh providing revenues for the
state um support a lot of things within
the retail uh and Food Service uh you
know hotels Etc um in terms of what
we've seen growing over the past uh few
years um we've seen construction
increase that's shouldn't be surprising
there's been a lot of focus particularly
in the legislature on changing some of
the uh land use rules land use statutes
that have propelled some additional
Construction in the state we've also
seen just natural demand and for more
housing result and more construction
naturally that leads to uh more people
in the construction industry more jobs
being posted there we've also seen
professional Technical Services increase
uh significantly as well um one of the
uh interesting statistics that I saw um
coming out of the really shift to remote
work is not only are a number of
companies now offering remote work as
compared to prior to
2020 um at least in and many of them are
offering part-time hybrid at the very
least um and that has had some um knock
on effects but it's also meant that
um companies that have have been able to
expand their Workforce without also
expanding their footprint um so they've
done things like um having people come
in uh one week and then have one week
remote and then they've been able to
expand and kind of shift that so they
have a second shift coming in week two
um and then week uh the next week they
are uh off so there's been some cost
savings there uh for businesses as
they've looked at expanding their
Workforce just a quick uh snapshot of of
jobs um and I believe you've already
seen this from New Hampshire employment
uh security
um uh where I just wanted to show you um
that we've increased uh total non-farm
payroll jobs um by 9,300 or 1.3%
uh from last year uh June to June that
is a that is a drop um from the prior
year 2.6% increase um so that's
something uh that I know a number of of
presenters already have indicated that
we want to keep an eye on we've seen
private education Health Services really
lead in terms of the uh overall number
of jobs that have been added to New
Hampshire's economy um so we want to
keep that in mind now one of the things
that we're keeping a close eye on is
labor force participation rate uh we are
currently
13th uh we have uh 6 65.1% participation
rate compared to a a uh
62.6% uh average rate um and
that's
not entirely surprising um we do have as
has been mentioned previously a higher
uh percentage of retirement age
individuals in the state um than many
other states so um the fact that we are
not uh we don't have as large a
percentage of our population in the
workforce is not
surprising um but that said it is
important to look at the decrease in
Workforce participation since 2020 to
see what we can find out uh so National
us chamber uh statistics show that
they're 1.7 million fewer Americans in
the workforce compared to February 20 uh
20 um and in New Hampshire even though
our population increased by about 17,700
people we saw a total decline of 7,800
people in the
workforce digging into that data um
we've seen a Workforce population
decline uh within the prime working age
is really one one of the major things
and that's certainly a concern um to
employers across the state
um we and one of the the area in
particular that we've seen increase in
um decline of popula and decline of
participation is the people who are
saying they're taking care of the house
or family um it's the largest and it's a
growing block of of individuals not
participating in the workforce um to the
best of our ability digging down into
that data we've really seen that this is
is due to child care Avail availability
well certainly some of those individuals
you know have uh new children they
voluntarily stay out of the workforce um
what we've heard both anecdotally and in
the data from Members is that um just
the availability of options for child
care has kept people out of the
workforce um so um just quickly
anecdotally um you know we've heard from
some members who have said they've had
anyone from new hires to to Executives
um who have had their first child um
they and their spouse have been put on
waiting lists for child care um baby
comes 9 months later and they never get
off the the uh the weight list there's
no option uh for them to you know do
something else with the baby um so
ultimately one of those uh parents has
to stay home uh you know that's
obviously a family choice for who that
is but we've heard from again anyone
from entry level to Executives so you're
taking you know highly skilled workers
out of the workforce um to care for a
child um simply because there is not uh
availability um what we've seen in terms
of child care providers across the state
is there's been a closure uh an
increased closure rate since 2019 that's
increased distances um so there are
fewer options for parents um they have
to drive further um which really
istically means we're taking more people
out of the workforce because further
isn't necessary an option um because New
Hampshire is such a small state we don't
have any good data New Hampshire
specific data on what the effect is on
the economy as far as we've been able to
find um but we do have data from the US
Chamber of Commerce Foundation um that
looked at some larger states that say
you know this is this is a billion
dollar problem uh Across the Nation we
can imagine um you know scaling that
down to New Hampshire that uh that it's
a problem here as well
um what we also want to point out is um
there have been some legislative changes
over the past couple years um in
particular last year homebased child
care providers uh the statutes related
to them um changed so that they the
number of children they can care for is
now regulated by DHHS rather than by
um necessarily by uh
municipalities uh generally speaking
that has allowed one additional child to
be cared for um per provider um so we
have seen some increase because of
policy changes uh at the state level um
we've also seen uh a shift in the market
um as other policies have changed uh
to change how uh eligibility for the
child care uh scholarship fund as well
as changes uh on a not an attendance
basis but an enrol e basis so that um
providers uh can rely on what their
income is and then base their business
model based on that so we have we've
made childcare more attractive for new
providers and for existing
providers um but there are certainly
still uh policy changes that could be
made that would increase um those
numbers I hope none of you ask me
questions about what those policy
changes could be because at this time
I'm not quite sure but I will do some
research to get back to you
um the uh in terms of a cost of Business
ranking um this is from
2023 uh New Hampshire has uh increased
our cost of of doing business um and the
cost uh for employers to uh to actually
engage in business um I'm going to talk
about some of those cost specifically um
some of that's going to relate to what
I've already said um some of those
include uh you know things like uh as
employers look at the availability of
child care and look at the cost of child
care I think the statistic came out I
think it was last month that in New
Hampshire for a family that has a
one-year-old and a four-year-old in
child care was something like3 or
$35,000 a year for that for that child
care that's obviously going to affect um
employees decisions about where to work
um as well as their their requests for
compensation um and when we dig into the
data at even the county level we see um
that we have a uh higher cost for
employers per hour worked for wages and
benefits than elsewhere in New England
and um elsewhere in the United States um
and we have some good uh breakdown of
that um obviously one of the big factors
is wages and one of those big wage
factors goes into it is the cost of
shelter um that's something I know
you've already heard about but I do want
to go into that a little bit today
because it is um it is a contributing
factor for people who are already secure
in their housing they already own their
house they have a fixed uh mortgage rate
this doesn't affect them if they're
working within kind of the reasonable
driving distance um but for people who
are uh you know looking for uh to Mo to
move in order to um fill a job that is
having a serious effect on both their
ability to do that because of the
availability of housing as well as
discussion with employers about what
wages are are
appropriate um you know wages obviously
have to have to approximate the cost of
living for employees otherwise people
aren't going to take the
jobs um and we see that many of the same
uh costs are going to affect both
business and employees so energy costs
for example um health care costs those
those have a pretty clear effect across
the board um one thing that I think
people are becoming more aware of is
that housing costs are as
well um so we've seen a 59% increase in
New Hampshire since quarter 1 of 2020 to
quarter 4 of
2023 that's higher now um and uh you
know the uh National Association of
Realtors came out with some good data
yesterday um and I do want to um just
read this to you um because I think it's
important uh monthly home payments on
starter homes have risen the most in New
Hampshire of all states um they've
surged 164% since
2019 that's as of the most recent data
from the National Association of
Realtors typical monthly mortgage
payments for a starter home in New
Hampshire is now $2,600 assuming a 10%
down payment which is the most common uh
down payment size uh that would require
an income of
$13,900 $85 to be considered affordable
that's for the lowest quarter lowest uh
quarter priced of houses so I I backed
into the numbers last night um because
one of the slides you'll see from the
Realtors um or have seen from the
Realtors is the average home price uh
which is about $563,000
now um average interest rates are
6.93% um one of the important things
because we are in New Hampshire to talk
about is the average property tax which
is a little bit over
$7,000 um I got that from the fiscal
policy Institute as well as um the
average homeowners insurance uh being
about $11,000 a year um so when I
computed this out uh I came up with the
average home uh you would need to make
$73,000 per year in order to make that
uh affordable to you meaning you're not
cost birden you're not paying more than
30% of your income uh for that uh that
shelter obviously rental costs are uh
similar on par I didn't do the math for
that um and just so the committee is
aware um the most recent data I could
pull said that uh 28% of uh employees in
New Hampshire make more than
$150,000 so when we're talking about
173,000 we're probably talking about 20%
or less of people who can afford the
average home in New Hampshire at this
point in
time um and we've seen a significant
decrease in home Inventory um and it's
our our opinion that really housing
costs are a supply and demand problem um
a healthy Supply available inventory
according to the real
is about 6 months of supply and we're
just shy of 2% at this point in time
that's up from what it was uh a couple
years ago um we've seen an increase in
building we've also seen National
interest rates which which correlate
with uh mortgage rates come down I think
the highest mortgage rates we saw were
above 7% um we're now down to slightly
less than uh
7% um but what we've one of the things
that I really want to focus on is the
decrease in supply of new housing um we
we haven't seen a decrease in Supply
because of demolition or natural
disasters like some other states have
seen um we've certainly seen an interest
rate increase um and that has caused a
mortgage rate locking effect so the
people who don't need to move um aren't
moving because they would uh they would
lose some of the um profits they would
have gained in their houses um but but
what we have seen uh since uh the Great
Recession is really a decrease in the
number of newly built housing units
which is a critical component of the
housing Supply um basically in 2011 we
saw very few houses built um we're
talking about you know maybe a couple
thousand in New Hampshire um that's down
from a high of over 9,000 at the peak of
the building boom in uh 20052 2006 six
um we've seen an increase since that
time um but we're nowhere close to that
Peak Peak uh building and we're actually
still under the historical average which
was just about uh 6,000 a year between
that 6 and 7,000 uh marks we've been
building fewer houses over the last
really decade and a half um than we have
traditionally um and while we saw
because of because of that building boom
in the uh mid 2000s some uh overs Supply
uh initially that was pretty quickly
eaten up by by if you look at it um by
2016 to
2018 that over Supply was was completely
gone
um uh and what we're seeing is that lack
of Supply is really driving uh housing
costs um you know as there are fewer uh
and fewer houses on the market um and
New Hampshire grows in population grows
um you know just in in people wanting to
uh to uh purchase homes um as family uh
Dynamics have have shifted um we've seen
that um that demand has has increased
and we've seen a decrease in um really
the ability of um the average uh median
income uh family to purchase homes um
really I want to talk about the
differential here between can I
interrupt you for a second we have a
question representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
I'm looking at this you you know if I go
back here a chart and we're talking
around uh 2004 5 and six you said about
9,000 units a year yep uh versus where
we're at today what is what shifted all
this so quickly I mean it seems to me
like it's not the Co obviously if we
dipped in 2011 to be in where were at
what was it
the a lot less units but so what's
driving this change from all this
housing availability to none yes or I
should say a small amount so the Great
Recession was uh caused in in large part
by a um crisis in of mortgage lending
and there were significant changes made
at the federal level for um who
qualified for mortgages as well as the
type of mortgages issued um so we saw a
shift in uh people who qualified and
that had an effect on on um demand at
that point in time but what we also saw
is because the Great Recession was so
long uh particularly in the construction
industry about in New Hampshire uh I
believe the data somewhere around 30% of
workers in the construction industry
lost their their jobs um and
and basically hiring and construction
did not occur again for 3 years so most
of that 30% moved on um they didn't go
back to the construction
industry um so you saw a decrease in
workers um you also saw um some shifts a
lot of the focus at the height of um I
guess I should back up a minute because
what you don't see in this chart is
really the historical um building prior
to uh 2001 so in the 1980s we had a big
building boom that happened uh usually
for easily accessible land land in New
Hampshire was a lot cheaper than
surrounding states particularly uh
Massachusetts uh and we saw a number of
neighborhoods built at that point in
time uh the reaction to that was at both
the state and local level was to put
into place a number of policies that
would slow growth um and through the 90s
we had
uh we didn't
have we had slightly lower uh
construction numbers um but because of
that large amount of of growth in the
late 80s early 90s it's what the um New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
called in 2002 kind of speculative
overgrowth um so we actually had enough
Supply at that point in time so you
didn't it kind of masked the effects of
the changes uh in the regulatory process
to prohibit that growth um and then you
saw with
um in the 2000s um you saw growth Across
the Nation in the number of houses being
built um because really uh the whole
industry was was so focused on this
growth um you saw that in New Hampshire
as well um you saw very clear uh you
know availability of materials there was
planning for that um and then um once
that hit and you lost a number of of
employees across the board um once you
lost that demand um it just simply
wasn't profitable to build anymore um
and you also had seen a lot of
development occur in um land that didn't
require a lot of site work it didn't
require a lot of effort to to build
there um and it was still relatively
cheap um since that time we've seen land
values increase significantly um
particularly in the Southeast where
we've seen a lot of the demand for um
not only workers in New Hampshire but
also servicing like the Boston and
Portland metro areas um we've seen uh so
we've seen those increase um we've seen
uh materials increase in cost
particularly post uh 2020 um I don't
remember off the top of my head the
exact statistic um but what we saw in
building materials inflation was
something like a 30 to 40% um there was
some pullback over 2002 2003 but it was
still about 30% I think it was above the
cost of those materials in 2019 um so
for Builders who are typically ordering
those materials as they need them um
it's really hard to price things because
you don't know um what that price is
going to be in two months when you get
to that particular uh house for example
so you saw a lot of contracts that had
in there Provisions for significant
increases above what had previously
occurred um and uh so overall it got
more expensive and of course at the same
time as this is getting more expensive
and workers are becoming more and more
scarce in this industry um they're
getting higher wages you're also having
them go on projects frankly that are
more profitable
um so you're not and and on the
regulatory side um you know some of the
shifts that occurred also occurred as
early as the 1970s where you saw really
a decrease in Nationwide in focus on
building what has been term starter
homes um but really what we're talking
about is like, 1400 foot homes the kind
of the modest homes that are you know
large two bedrooms one bath or uh you
know a small three-bedroom one one one
and a half bath type things and you
really saw a shift from uh the early
1980s of those being about a quarter of
the housing units built to by the time
we're hitting 2005 um you know just
regulatory changes across the board
those are less than 20% of of the
housing units being built so from 40 to
20% significant shift and as people are
looking at um you know affordability now
what I think a lot of the conversation
you're probably hearing is well let's
build more of those houses um because
simply there isn't there aren't many of
them and we've seen a significant
population growth across the United
States yes very good thank you I I've
seen where they've had these micro home
Villages they're building they're really
tiny homes and they twist and turn them
so they have some privacy and but I I
saw myself price of a 2x4 go from like
$2 to $9 so y thank you represent
elberger thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I represent
the city of NASA mhm or part of the city
of NASA and NASA is a border Community
we are just over the line from
Massachusetts I have a fair number of
constituents who work in Massachusetts
because their salaries are significantly
higher I'm thinking in particular of
teachers and police officers who can
earn $220,000 a year more in
Massachusetts
I'm looking at the chart uh the slide
number 25 the housing price increase
Massachusetts is the only state in New
England where there was under a 50%
increase in housing prices their
salaries are
higher I'm wondering what the impact of
salaries are and the fact that salaries
in New Hampshire are often significantly
lower than those in
Massachusetts and how do we deal with
the impact of those lower salaries on
the fact that our housing prices have
increased so much that people can't
afford to buy or live
here uh thank you for the question
so I don't know that I have a good
answer for you um on that uh obviously
when we're talking about um teachers uh
Etc um those wages are set um by Town
media here in New Hampshire um I'm not
sure exactly how they're set in
the I think
um one of the important things to look
at I think is
probably that differential between home
values and household income I'm not
familiar with Massachusetts but I can
talk a little bit about Texas if that's
helpful um because I looked into that
last year um Texas overall has lower
salaries than we have in New England and
in New Hampshire for the same jobs um
they also have lower home values but one
of the things that you've seen in in
Texas and I'm talking about Houston in
particular is um that if you were to map
out their increases in the differential
change um between their income s and the
increase in home uh home prices it
basically is the same graph as I'm
showing you right now um so I think one
of the things that New Hampshire is
struggling with along with other states
is you know how do we close this Gap um
and that's again um a challenge um there
are a number of things that we at the
state level don't control we don't
control interest rates um obviously if
interest rates were lower
uh people could afford uh higher priced
homes um because of the monthly payment
difference
um there are uh you know one of the
things we've seen at the federal level
for example is in the
1970s uh there was significant Federal
investment in water and sewer
infrastructure um that uh allows
building at higher densities we haven't
seen that type of investment uh at the
federal level since then but one of the
things that that Federal investment did
in a lot of places was it allowed the
building of uh water treatment
facilities that were not only um not
only sized for the existing population
but also future population growth so
that absorbed some of that um some of
those costs as well um and what we've
also seen is really kind of a uh a shift
in that that demand um New Hampshire uh
because of you know it's a great place
to live um has really attracted a
significant number of people as compared
to uh you know percentage wise compared
to Massachusetts uh more people have
left Massachusetts than have moved there
um and they've been coming to States
like ours which has put an an increased
uh Demand on our our housing prices
which or on our housing availability
which is increased prices um I don't
know that that entirely gets to your
question but I hope that's some helpful
background data followup followup I'm
one of those people by the way I moved
here from Massachusetts four years ago
five years ago uh but I'm also wondering
you talked about the federal investment
in infrastructure has there been any
state
investment yes so we have uh state aid
grants that Dees administers um those
are for maintenance not for new water
and
infrastructure um that has been funded
uh traditionally between and $15 million
a year um I'm sure Dees could speak more
about it than I can um I believe there's
legislation this year to make it 15
million a year um the other other state
investment that we've done recently is
the housing Champions program which was
started up a couple years ago um it's up
for renewal in this budget cycle it was
initially um funded with5 million but
one of the specific parts of that
legislation and then the rules actually
uh say that it's for additional monies
for new infrastructure so it's not just
um not just uh not just maintenance um
we have uh traditionally invested um in
kind of roads which are also expensive
Bridges which are also expensive um as
part of the state budgeting process
uh we've done that um a lot of that
through uh Highway block grants um but
if there has been surpluses in the past
the legislature has been uh very
generous in providing additional Aid
particularly to municipalities with uh
those Road and Bridge monies thank you
representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for
taking my
question
um since Ways and Means Main respon
responsibility is to determine uh
Revenue projections mhm uh you indicated
that there's been an increase of up 10%
I believe you said that has
occurred concerning manufacturing here
in the
state yet we seem to be losing U uh
employees from the Deputy Commissioner
the Department of Employment Security
yesterday yesterday and the economic and
labor market information Bureau you said
lost about, 1300 they seem to have said
that we're
1,592
employees or laborers or or
workers is there a reason for
that um so just so I can clarify about
10% of our Workforce uh is employed in
manufacturing is what I meant to say in
terms of the losses um I believe I have
data that's from a different point in
time I'm sure theirs is more current
than the data that I have um so I would
defer to them for those exact numbers
and my
followup um since you brought up data uh
do you have data
uh to show how the uh tax rate
reductions initiated by the New
Hampshire legislature have
increased uh in migration of the
manufacturing and Industrial Footprints
here in New Hampshire I do not have that
you okay can oh question represent and
you get that data I can try to find that
data um I will do my best to find it and
provide that to uh the
thank you
uh it how could you possibly get that
data given that that there are so many
factors that were involved the pandemic
the The Great Well the Great Recession
was before that but the the Tale on the
Great
Recession um
and and the um everything that is
changing in the National
economy let me rephrase if that data
exists and I can find the person or
entity that has it I will provide that
to the committee thank
you yes represent
oling these slides that you have could
you uh make them available to the entire
uh committee through I've I've provided
um so just moving on to uh electricity
prices here
um uh what you've seen uh and we've
talked about previously is over the the
past um really decade and a half uh New
Hampshire's increased more uh in terms
of electricity prices than um any other
state uh most other states uh were're
60.7% increase um only 11 other states
have seen such a high rise in
prices um so one of the one of the
requests from our members particularly
manufacturing which uses a high
percentage of electricity is uh for
policy options that help them reduce
those costs um because that makes New
Hampshire more attractive for them um
obvious obviously that's an interest and
given that the new incoming Federal
administration's focus is to increase um
State Side manufacturing um certainly
anything we can do to make New Hampshire
more attractive um would be helpful uh
in that
Arena um in terms of overall
infrastructure rankings um we uh one of
the areas that we actually do really
well on that I know commissioner Caswell
uh mentioned um we don't actually have
uh kind of rolled out in terms of data
and ranking at this moment in time but
is broadband infrastructure that's in
large part to um both federal and state
investment in that um and so I know he
covered that pretty
extensively um but o overall we do have
a lower investment in just
infrastructure across the board whether
we're talking about roads Bridges um you
know anything else um compared to other
states um I know I'm pretty much out of
time here so I'm happy to uh stop
talking if you'd like me to Mr
chair well if you would like to just
um I guess um get you know finalize it
get to your key takeaways uh that would
be good yeah I will skip ahead to that
um so as I began this presentation with
uh New Hampshire's overall business
climate strong in position to compete na
nationally um really Workforce
availability and housing Supply which
are intertwined um are the top risk
factors in our business climate followed
by the Avail availability of child care
energy costs some of those um existing
uh cost concerns uh such as health
care um and we're hoping that uh the
state legislature Embraces Statewide
Solutions and promotes Regional
Solutions um to help really increase uh
economic output throughout the
state thank you um I had I have a
question about business formation you
had I think if I remember correctly New
Hampshire was 14th in business formation
and uh our our uh business formation fee
I believe is $100 and the ongoing annual
report fee is $100 how does that how
does that rank do you know fairly low in
in the country at $100 I don't I don't
know off the top of my head but I could
find out in the the states that rank
higher what theirs are okay because I
know Massachusetts is 500 which is sign
signicantly
larger representative
opal uh thank you Mr chairman and um
thank you Mr Grace for your presentation
I I I couldn't help but notice um in
your chart uh the state
ranks significantly high in terms of
um I forget exactly how you call it but
we were sixth in terms of our tax
climate for business MH um and
yet um on another slide the cost of
Business ranking in 2023 it looks like
we've slipped in the last 10 years
despite a series of tax cuts um for
business we've slipped 18 places we've
gone from 18th to
36th
um every Economist every business person
I've ever talked to says that obviously
taxes are an important calculation for
business but they're certainly not the
only calculation in many cases they're
not the first
calculation um and it it would seem to
me your key
takeaways um the cost of our business
ranking
decline has less to do with cutting
taxes and more to do with the fact that
child care Workforce housing housing
generally energy cost cost as you point
out um are are significant impact in
terms of the ability to hire and conduct
business um so I'm wondering if you
think that um while this committee's
focus is obviously on revenue for the
state I'm wondering if you think that um
perhaps our focus should be on Revenue
to solve some of these problems as it
would appear your third bullet point
well thank you for the question um you
know the focus uh of our economic
briefing today was hopefully to
highlight some of the emerging
challenges that we saw um as I mentioned
uh you know when we're looking at
workers who need to relocate to take
positions we're looking at businesses
we're trying to hire qualified
candidates from out of a reasonable
travel distance um what challenges are
they facing and what level can state
government pull to make that easier um
in terms of uh you know Revenue
projections uh how the state takes that
in and what you use that for that's
really beyond the scope of what I'm
prepared to talk about
today thank you did you
representative thank you on on your
points um regarding housing and child
care
do you have any data or access to data
that would indicate the type of local
and state
regulations
that complicate the availability of
housing
so both of these topics are incredibly
complicated which I can base
not only in my knowledge of that but
based on the fact that there seem to be
somewhere upwards of 50 bills filed on
different Housing Solutions this session
um all of which propose uh various
things that that may help uh ease the
supply crunch here um I think it's
important to
uh keep in mind um that because of the
complicated nature of this I don't have
a a sing Le solution I can certainly
provide you some data on different
options uh for example um you know I am
aware of the fact that there's something
like a 500 page book on parking and how
that affects the
availability of of building um which is
more than I would ever care to read um
um but there are a lot of factors that
go into that and help developers pencil
these things out so I think there are a
number of options um depending on what
we want the state to look like in 5
years for uh what what availability is
there uh
followup yeah parking traffic studies
I'm on a local planning board don't go
strategies watching the the the effect
of regulation in
ibit uh good utilization not maximum
utilization because you know person has
a right to their own property and to
develop it in the way they want but to
utilize and come up with a uh permissive
uh not permissive an environment in
which a person can develop property to
increase the housing right
plus
um lowering the cost of electricity when
we can't even get inexpensive hydr power
to come down to New
Hampshire how does the state come up
with Statewide strategies when a lot of
other stuff interferes that makes it
more difficult and more expensive for me
home well I think that's a significant
challenge representative bery um uh you
know and uh I think it's
um unfortunately a policy by policy
basis um so if there are things that can
be done that uh sort
of have an effect uh that that
um that are supported um broadly and
also
um you know look at saving um taxpayer
funds so for example um in many
downtowns across the state um you know
you can go to the downtown see what it
looks like and many of them have a
vacant lot nearby that's in kind of a
residential area um but if you were to
propose the type of building that exists
in the surrounding lots that may not be
allowed under the local zoning code so
figuring out what policy levers to pull
in order to enable that type of uh that
type of development which is what
historically has been there um might be
helpful so to give you a good example um
doing a simple zoning change bringing
that to as I'm sure you know better than
I do bringing that to the local
legislative body to vote on costs
between $5 and $110,000 because you have
to have someone draft it you have to put
all those notices out you have to have
the hearing you have to have staff there
to take all the minutes you have to do
all of these administrative processes
just to have that vote um when we're
talking about um you know trying to make
significant changes at the local level
those dollars add up um one of the
programs that is administered out of uh
invest inh and and now housing Champions
um that Bea administers um provides
Housing Opportunity what are called
Housing Opportunity grants that help
fund or kick start funding some of those
rewrites at the local level of
zoning um but you also have some
probably some pretty good data from
collected by agencies like Bea about you
know what do people think about when
they go and actually vote on this stuff
what do they actually think about things
like adus for example and and what do
people say and then I think as policy
makers you have to make the decision
about you know is it worth costing uh
you know letting letting this process
play out or is it the case that we have
good data that that's something that's
broadly
supported thank you representative
M and I'm going to take one more
question after this and then we'll
because we're getting late thank you Mr
chairman uh thanks for taking my
question um given some of the the the
ongoing challenges that businesses face
that you mentioned housing Child Care
electricity costs is there any data
available that that shows how many of
the new companies that are formed
survive through you know a period of
time three five years so that you kind
of have a an we have an idea of kind of
the net the net um uh company creation
if if you if you know what I mean I
understand your question so I'll as I
said earlier if such data exists and I
can find the person who has it I will
find it and provide it to the committee
great thank you very
much representative ORS thank you Mr
chair and thanks again for taking my
question uh I'm gonna alter my question
just a little bit based on what the rep
asked but so if we uh our energy costs
are so high we know that blue States
continue to block the pipelines where we
could increase the flow of natural gas
and reduce our electricity costs in
order to put more money back in the
pockets of parents that need child care
and so on are is the B a pushing to
increase the nuclear energy Supply in
New Hampshire so that we can reduce our
costs and maybe sell that extra Supply
off to other states thank you thank you
for the question representative I
actually have a copy of our 2025 policy
priorities that I can provide to you
after the hearing um I as I recall it I
don't believe we specifically have a
policy on nuclear energy uh I know our
general policy is in all of the the
above policy uh to support policies that
would according to the our knowledge of
it support uh decreased energy costs as
far as that specific question goes I
don't know the answer to that that's
something I would have to bring to our
board of directors to uh decide what
they would like to do would love to get
an answer on that thank
we'll now hear from the New Hampshire
you
okay
yes maybe we could because we do we do
all have a handout and uh so if we could
yourselves my name is Bob Quinn I am the
CEO of the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors my name is Sarah Holland I am
the chair of public policy for the New
Hampshire Association Realtors and I am
primarily a residential
broker good morning my name is Chris
Norwood I am the vice chair for the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors public
policy committee and my background is in
commercial real estate brokerage so
trying to talk about that intersection
between the the presentation you just
heard and uh in the real estate
well I think we're gonna have some
slides up in a
moment um so I know that uh you've
already had everyone wants to talk about
housing both Jason and N already
provided uh a number of data points
points on that so I will do my best not
to repeat what they say but I didn't see
all of nature so I apologize if that's
the case so we have ended 2024 the
median sale price in New Hampshire for
single family home ended at
$514,000 so as you can see that's the
first time we've ever crossed the
$500,000 Mark in fact uh this past
summer we topped off at median sale
price of $540,000
so you can see that there has been a um
this is goes back to 2005 a study
increase in median sale
price it's maybe hard for folks to see
but um this these are the median sale
price of every year going back to
1998 um so in 2016 median sale price was
about
$250,000 Statewide so since 2016 we are
up
105% in in terms of uh sale price um
while median income has risen by 50% so
median income at 50 housing prices since
105% and you can see that during um we
have seen increases uh in median sale
price every year going
back oh sorry well I was just going to
point out that um the median sale price
uh has gone up every year um since
2011 I believe it is uh and in most
inflation so uh this next slide is sort
of the homes for sale uh every month
over since um January 1st of 2021 so you
can see that 2024 we did have an
increase in inventory over
2023 um not by a lot but we did
if you compare 2024 to both 2022 and
2021 you'll see it looks awfully similar
all right so yes you're going to see in
um reports of increase in total number
of homes for sale but I think it's
important to look at that's generally
compared to the previous year if you
kind of take a longer view on that this
is same information but there goes back
to 2025
so you can see that starting really
about 2014 2015 we start to see a
decrease in homes for sale in New
Hampshire um the we get to the covid
2020 and you see a dip um but I think
it's fair to say that if the rate of
decrease continued on from 2019 until
today we kind of would have gotten to
the same point uh Co kind of made us
Sprint there along that path but we were
headed that way anyway I'd also want to
point out just you'll see a little red
dot there uh in 2016 uh I'll get to that
a little bit but that is um the last
time that what we determine is a
balanced housing market a balanced
housing market means the buyers and
sellers are an equal footing during
negotiations right so the last time that
was um we can see there were about 7500
homes for sale Statewide um we barely
are topping out on a monthly basis at
2500 this year so we're about a third
the number of homes for
sale so when we talk about a balanced
supply of
housing uh it's every if you took all
the homes that are on the market today
at the current absorption rate the
demand for housing how long would it
take to eliminate all of the housing
that was available today you want that
to be 6 months we want six months of
housing inventory that's a balance
Market buyers and sellers on equal
footing five might be the low range um
but you really want six so in December
we had 1.9 months all right so and you
can see that it has been a steady
decline uh over the past 10 12 years of
housing inventory in the state and again
that red line that red marker is the
the next chart here is what we call our
affordability index so this charts three
different factors what is the median
sale price in any given month what is
the median income family income in the
state of New Hampshire and that and what
are the Prevailing mortgage rates so it
sort of tracks what could a median
family a family earning the median
income
afford so that means if the the that
index is at 100 that means the median
income in the state can afford the
median sale
price you really want to see that number
at 120 130 that means a majority of New
Hampshire residents can afford the
median sale price home and you can see
if you go back to 20 even 2018 and by
the way this the gold is single family
the blue is condo um so if you go back
to you know
2017 um we saw number is in the 150
range the 2024 ended up with an index of
58 that means the median income in the
state of New Hampshire is only 58% of
what it takes to buy that
$514,000 home um that means an awful lot
of people in New Hampshire are simply
priced out they cannot afford uh housing
in the state so keep in mind there are
three factors to that if we're going to
increase that number back up to where it
should be
you can either increase um median
income which is going to be I would
argue at least from our perspective a
challenge to do as what n just mentioned
how do businesses grow uh if they cannot
find the workers because they don't have
the housing to supply that for the
workers um the other issue is um we see
a change in mortgage rates um mortgage
rates right now hovering varies and you
can get different rates but let's call
it 7% now um but keep in mind as
inventory was dropping in 15 16 17 18 in
New Hampshire um mortgage rates were
between 3 and 5% um most of the
economist that we've seen nationally
whether or not it's our own National
Association of Realtors the home
builders um I haven't seen anybody who
have suggested that in the next year
mortgage rates are going to drop below
6% most of them are predicting they're
going to be somewhere in the vicinity of
6.5 um and by the way interest rates I
think we've had three reductions in the
interest rates um since Labor Day
mortgage rates have gone up since that
point mortgage rates don't track
interest rates mortgage rates track um
the 10-year treasury uh so um that's a
better indicator of where mortgage rates
go so U again just sort of the same
information but this is now looking over
the past three years we're just seeing a
steady decline in affordability in the
state um and the ability of people in
New Hampshire to buy a
home is it a and I think n may have
brought up something similar is this a
New Hampshire issue or is this just
we're part of a national Trend so these
are County medium sale prices in every
County in the country um the blue are
the less expensive um and as you see the
red and the orange those are the most
expensive Rockingham County is in the
top 2 and a half% of median sale price
homes in the entire country so of all
the counties it's in the top 2 and a
half% every County except Sullivan and
Coos in New Hampshire is in the top
10% um so you can see that there is a in
the Northeast part of the the country
there is um prices have are are higher
elsewhere and again I think Nate had a
similar slide on home price appreciation
since the arrival of covid um so New
Hampshire's since um this is 2020
quarter 1 to 2024 quarter 3 um so New
Hampshire median sale price has
increased
68.3%
um
the and we are fourth in the country uh
in terms of increase in housing prices
um I will point out that of those four
states you see in front of front of you
New Hampshire's current median sale
price is about 50 to 75 ,000 higher so
we were at a higher point and we're
increasing at pretty much the same rate
than our neighboring states as well as
Florida I think Florida is about 420 430
right now in terms of their median sale
price while we're at 4 514
so we are a little bit unique I would
argue so um part of uh I think as you
look at where real estate transfer taxes
might go other taxes it's going to be a
lot of it how was is part of it is sort
of the psychology of you know what is
going to prompt and motivate people to
move um there is a lot of discussion
about sort of the mortgage lock concern
a lot of folks in New Hampshire have
mortgages at 3% 4% they look at a
mortgage at s and they say they don't
want to buy they don't want to sell they
want to keep their 3 to 4 per. so there
there is a factor um that plays into the
lower mortgage rates getting closer um
the but each year move forward there are
fewer percentage of folks who have those
mortgages under 6% we did do a a poll
though we asked sort of trying to get to
the psychology of what's going to have
folks move uh in the upcoming year so we
did a Statewide poll of residents in
early
December and we asked them first of all
do you see a lack of housing inventory
in your own home in your own Community
excuse me um and you can see 60% say the
availability of housing is a big problem
only 18% said it is not a problem um
similar numbers a little higher uh when
we ask the question do you think there's
enough housing types um so you have
single family condos and and most people
not almost half of the
residents say that uh their rent or
mortgage puts a significant strain on
their budget um and that is up with
asked the exact same question in 2019 so
as you saw that affordability index
dropping um it's pretty obvious that
this corresponds to that they're they're
they're feeling the you can look at the
numbers the showing that incomes are not
keeping up with housing and now you see
corresponding that it they're they're
they're recognizing that and indicating
that it's a a greater
strain and shelter costs rent mortgages
usually are for most of us uh the
largest line item in your monthly budget
so when that you feel the strain in that
you feel uh problems with with your
current situation
economically um so and I think this is
um a real concern is most folks in New
Hampshire a large about half of folks in
New Hampshire um currently are not
confident that the types of housing in
their own Community would meet their
needs um so if if they had to move about
half of the folks in the state of New
Hampshire now say I'm not sure I could
afford to live uh in my own Community if
I have to move um so that's a real
concern uh as well and maybe kind of
inhibiting folks from moving and we
asked the same question in 2019 and it's
up significantly it went from 27% up to
48% so to try and make a pitch here in
terms of you know maybe represent R's
question about what can be done um
imagine you're a young couple or you're
older young couple starting a family or
an older couple looking to downsize you
want to build a nice 2,000t home um have
a nice little backyard you can do on a
quarter acre you go out you can find a
quarter an acre let's just say and it
varies very greatly depending on where
you are in the state but let's just say
it's
$40,000 you can do that the town
government comes back and says sorry
that's illegal you can't build that home
on a quarter acre you need an a full
acre know in some areas that might mean
your $40,000 now that you're ready to
put down for land it could be 160
probably not you can probably figure out
a way but it's going to increase it by
at least 50% if not more so the
government regulations on that are in
playing an important role and
exacerbating the affordability crisis in
the state so I think that there are
options um that this legislature be
looking at in the upcoming year to sort
of help um resolve some of those issues
and with that I think I'm done in moment
me switch to I'm going to turn this over
to
Sarah thank you again for having us um
so I I want to put um you know kind of
some a human perspective on this a
little bit relative to keeping folks in
their communities to be able to grow
those roots sustain those roots um
create that Legacy and to build that
Workforce that we're all looking for for
all those Industries and businesses that
are looking to come in so this slide was
utilized in a business and economy um uh
conference a number of years ago and it
really illustrates the different types
of housing that may be needed by an
individual person over their lifetime
and right now with our lack of available
types of housing within individual
communities anyone that is experiencing
um a temporary transition um uh looking
for a rental maybe they're up they're
having a child and they need a little
bit more space any one of these Life
Changes may have them moving outside of
the community or outside of the state
because there's not enough housing
options within their Community to keep
them where they are and there's an
argument to be made and and history
shows us that communities that have
really strong bonds that are healthy
have all different types of Housing and
that are able to retain their community
members for long periods of time and
including Generations so if we don't
have that available housing stock to
keep people in the communities that
they're at then they're going to leave
so the the folks that are exiting our
our state and our towns um are going to
other places seeking something more
affordable where they can put down roots
and we're seeing folks coming in to do
the same here but there's no place for
to go they're often um leaving very
shortly thereafter some of the data that
we've looked at um those numbers are
quick turnaround folks purchased homes
to come here during covid and they're
like this isn't for me and they sold and
they left and now we have new faces in
our community so one of the one of the
um arguments that we see a lot about
um changing some rules and regulations
to allow more Housing and Community
is that rural character and I don't want
to say I cracked the code on Rural
character and what it means because it's
really difficult to qu quantify but I
think it's that feeling of community
when you walk into your grocery store
your doctor's office um when you go to
the town office you're seeing the same
faces over and over and over again which
is an economic Plus for our communities
because we don't have that change over
over and over again we create those
bonds we get people to stay here longer
who stay at their jobs um my husband's
been at his position for over 30 years
that is very difficult to find nowadays
um but he was fortunate to grw up in the
community in which he now still stays in
we can't leave because there's no place
for us to really go so I think it's
important that we put um a personal uh
like a human face to some of these
statistics these are real people that
we're talking about
um and if you think about your own lives
and what it is that you have encountered
throughout your lifetime and what your
children and your grandchildren are
about to encounter that you want them to
stay close you want them to stay in New
Hampshire you want them to stay in their
communities and love where they live
because they're going to talk about it
and attract more business more other
more Workforce to come and stay here um
and be able to keep those businesses and
that our economy
thriving um and with that maybe I'm
going to hand it over to Chris so we got
we can
uh move you along Sarah and I handled
the residential side and Chris is going
to talk about commercial real estate um
if I can May interrupt for a minute we
have a question from represent elme
thank you uh that slide in particular
leads me to ask are you going to send us
the digital
you uh could you jump jump to the next
slide
there so uh what you see in front of you
is uh specific to the commercial side of
the real estate transfer tax so again my
background is in commercial real estate
and what I'm uh trying to ground the
conversation here is the amount of real
estate transfer tax that's generated by
the residential transfers that Bob and
Sarah have been talking about versus the
commercial transfers so uh I probably
should have put an interim slide in here
but just to put it in kind of gross
dollar amounts um uh
2022 our transfer stamps in the state of
New Hampshire according to the
Department of Revenue were around uh
$232 uh
million um as you can see on my
calculation there um of that 232 around
38 million of that were commercial
transactions so you're talking uh you
know quick math is probably around uh
15% give or take um in
2023 you can see the uh the volume of
commercial real estate transfer tax
declined down to 15 million uh and then
um a slight uptick based upon um my
projections of $19 million so what this
slide is is hoping to try and capture
for you is that when you look at the
real estate transfer stamps which um is
is uh
$150 per every hundred thou for every
,000 transferred paid by the buyer and
the seller we're looking at somewhere
around 80% of that being generated by
the single family condominium
residentials and land sales that Bob and
Sarah were talking about and somewhere
between 10 and 20% commercial i' I'd
like to also note that there is around a
5 or a 10% Gap if you were to add up all
of Bob and Sarah's numbers and my
numbers and that's due to the fact that
there are off-market transfers there's
also transfers that are not necessarily
cleanly uh single family or commercial
it could be a mixed use development uh
those types of things so when we're
talking about the real estate transfer
stamps um solely just transfer stamps uh
the residential sales are clearly the
economic engine to bring in that 200 I
think 2020 4 numbers were estimated to
be around 183 million my reading of the
U New Hampshire Business Review stated
so um happy to answer any questions on
this or anything else relating to that
intersection of real estate and uh in
business thank you representa
Aly thank you on when you say commercial
do you include commercial residential
that is the apartment buildings that are
built solely to ramp
yes thank you uh representative for the
question uh yes this data is provided
the commercial portion of this data is
provided by an aggregator called co-star
um and you may be familiar with some of
their products
apartments.com uh loopnet co-star But to
answer your question yes that includes
the transfer of uh multif family
investment
property thank you and do you do you
look at uh the effect of property taxes
as
well uh thank you representative for the
question I was looking solely at the
transfer stamps uh I have not looked at
the valuation component and the revenue
municipalities uh representa
M yeah I have a question on the uh uh
commercial properties you've said that
the some of the commercial properties
are up of the investors investing in
residential property I'm curious about
just straight business property what do
you see the trends in business property
transactions thank you representative
for the question so keeping this slide
on the on the screen what you can see
here this is anecdotal I don't have
straight concrete evidence but what I
believe was happening in 2020
2021 into this peak of 2022 where we had
had 2 and A2 billion worth of commercial
transfers and it has since declined you
had a lot of money on the sidelines in
2020 and
2021 when people really were unsure of
themselves and unsure of where they
wanted to be deploying their Capital uh
and then you had
simultaneously um a lot of federal
stimulus funds right we can talk about
the arpa or any other acronyms that I'm
not going to be able to remember but
there's a lot of federal stimulus coming
through and so I I think that the uh the
increase of commercial transactions
going from about 10% of the overall real
estate transfer tax up to um 15% was
partially on interest partially on or
interest rates partially on Lower
construction costs and partially just a
ton of capital that was completely
paused for 20120 and
2021 so I I hope that answers the
question
if I could follow up so what do you
project for the trends going forward in
the next two years for commercial real
estate you think that's going to be
holding study in terms of Supply demand
is that someone in balance or is it way
out of balance like we see in the
residential side thank you
representative for the question I I do
think that it is uh out of balance but
you have to talk in specifics to
property classes so when I think of
things that are out of balance I'm
thinking specifically industrial
property
um what coming out of the pandemic many
businesses basically said I don't want
to be caught in the supply chain bind
again so I'm going to bring all my
warehousing inh house I'm going to bring
extra production in house I'm going to
get that extra 10,000 square fet 50,000
square feet so as a result our
industrial Market has increased steadily
not necessarily pertinent to today but
for my entire 20-year career interest uh
sorry rental rates for industrial
property have always been like six bucks
a foot I could set my watch to it now
rental rates in the southern part of our
state are in double digits per square
foot you know you're it's not uncommon
to see $1 11 122 a square foot which is
very very uncommon so representative to
your question I think it's very asset
class specific I think industrial is
very very tight retail is moderately an
office despite the headlines that you
read that office is uh on its behind I
think that that's more um specific to
Boston and the New Yorks of the world
New Hampshire in general uh has been
very fortunate in our office supply uh
we did not overbuild and also you see
some of the Office Inventory being
converted to residential uses so you see
the the denominator decreasing for some
of the office
classes okay I have multiple questions
from people so I'm going to try to go in
the order that I saw the hands raised so
thank you very much for taking my
question um I'm representative wrong I'm
on the finance committee but um I'm
looking at your slide 11 regarding the
um almost half people say their rent or
mortgage puts a significant or slight
strain on their budget um have you been
looking at the dynamic that's been
occurring at least in my town of miramac
where the increased house values and the
increase is driving an increase in
residential assessment at a much greater
rate than what we're seeing in
commercial and Industrial and so the the
T the local property taxes are going up
for residents even without an increase
in spending because they're taking more
of the burden of the the townwide
assessment has that has that been a
factor at all in any of the the data
you've been looking at or is it
something you're tracking because
commercial Industrials now paying lower
taxes than they would otherwise because
of the assessment shift
yeah um so thank you representative for
the question I um I'd have to give it a
little bit more thought I think from
just a high level um commercial taxes I
mean for towns unlike Massachusetts
which has an equalization ratio for New
Hampshire sorry for commercial versus
residential property in the state of New
Hampshire we do not have that same um
Equalization ratio that you would
otherwise have in Massachusetts so in
theory there should be a uh an even
playing field I I would have to really
look into the increase burden of of
uh valuations I think is your question
representative because uh you know
commercial values have gone up as well
um not quite as dramatically as
residential valuations but yes all all
valuations are going up okay thank
you and I think that it's also important
to note
that there are a number of factors that
are associated with the increase in in
one's tax bill right so um current use
is a is a factor in reducing that
taxation for larger tracks of land lots
of municipalities are putting land in um
into conservation in order to um to
preserve that open space and none of
these things are right or wrong they
just are and they're kind of part of of
the the web that we have to kind of
navigate here but the property taxes are
are a huge burden for folks we everybody
just got their their newest uh
assessment and Bill and I know in my my
municipality folks are really struggling
which makes me very nervous about what
is to happen um when folks are not able
to to pay that tax bill and the burden
on the municipalities and then
eventually the state on taking those
properties back who is going to be
purchasing them those folks that are
displaced where do they go um and that's
a that's a real concern that folks are
talking about on the local level yeah
representative
ulery thank you we've had some rather
large commercial
industrial warehousing spaces built
particularly in my
town well over a million square feet uh
London der has had a bunch Salems had
some um there was even one up off root
102 I saw the other day I think it was
in Candia or one of I'm not sure one of
facility you would mention that there
were some corporations that were
concerned about the supply chain and
decided to put the remote uh
warehousing
distributed State side as opposed to on
time shipping from China or France or
wherever um
the question is those large
facilities have added to the tax base of
the
communities which have resulted
in more capital or more Revenue to the
communities what happened to the tax
rate on the property that should have
been offset on that do you have any data
on
that uh thank you representative for the
question um no I I don't have any value
valuation is similar to representative
Run's question um I I think I would have
to you know on a property by propy basis
what was that land doing prior to was it
as Sarah suggested sitting in current
use whereby it wasn't being taxed and
now it's being taken out of current use
there's a penalty associated with that
and now you have a 30 foot clear High
100,000 foot industrial building being
taxed at x 50 foot
500,000 square foot and two of them but
I think representative to your point
about the the clear height there is a
question of obsolescence meaning that we
have a lot of industrial inventory that
was built in the 80s um
24,200 ft buildings there were a ton of
them built up around the airport in in
nashwa and we needed a revitalization of
our industrial stock so part of this was
a lot of pent up demand that you had
been needing for about two
decades thank
Maguire so um there were there going to
be there were about 12,000 single family
home sales uh in
2024 we have seen that number 17 18,000
in previous years and I have some
figures I can distribute to afterwards
that uh have that those
numbers so so so we said I heard earlier
that the goal was to have 8,000 building
significant
imp yeah so the housing shortage that we
have currently in this moment is over
20,000 and by 2040 we're looking at a
shortage of
990,000 so um adding yes it will make a
small a small dent um but we really need
to reduce as many barriers as possible
to be able to add um housing
opportunities of all types um and
especially in in the infill um using
existing infrastructure so we don't
increase those costs so that would look
like
adus um and and filling out communities
Cottage courts those types of things um
which will also take that tax burden in
a community and spread it amongst more
Property Owners which in theory is going
to reduce the overall um tax bill for
each one of those community
Stringham yeah so um first to the number
of um the the number of homes that were
were needed currently those numbers the
20,000 today and the 990,000 by 2040
also includes shortterm some short-term
rental stock because that is in our
history in New Hampshire as a tourist
destination so we shouldn't think that
those are going to go away we just need
to account for them um we did have some
numbers and maybe Bob can speak to that
um but when we're looking at short-term
rentals there is a subset that is um for
investment only so non-owner occupied
but there are a number of folks who are
utilizing short-term rentals to be able
to pay their tax bill right so if they
do have an Adu um and it's it's usually
just a short-term solution for most to
kind of get over the hump um me as an
investor I purchased a property in
Northern New Hampshire as a vacation
home I did the short-term rental thing
for a very short period of time it was
not for me and there are a lot of folks
that are like me that are and and I did
sell it to somebody who now lives there
full-time as a primary residents where
it was not that prior to my ownership so
I think the it's a very small subset
that are doing short-term rentals purely
as
investment yeah if you want to dig into
that a little deeper both the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority as
well as the main Finance Authority um
looked into that issue and study the
impact on inventory as well as rental
prices and I think I can summarize both
of them saying that it didn't have an
impact on either one and if you think
about it it kind of makes sense a lot of
what's used for short-term rentals if
they are the ski condos up by Waterville
or loon um and uh and and New Hampshire
has always had uh a large number of
second Homes New Hampshire Vermont and
Maine rank one two and three in terms of
the percentage of homes which are used
as secondary homes uh and that's been
years representative elberger followed
by
shamberg thank you Mr Mr chair um you
answered the first question I was going
to ask you just now about secondary
second homes but the other question that
I have has to do with I will speak again
for nasua the number of storefronts uh
commercial properties that are empty has
been increasing over the last several
years uh given the rise in online
commercial activity it seems unlikely
that those properties are going to be
utilized as new commercial
properties what what are you seeing or
might you be seeing in terms of
potentially uh redesigning those
properties as Residential
Properties uh thank you representative
for the question I think for uh you know
particularly downtown environments well
let's just talk retail in general I
think retail in general over the last 20
years has really become more
experience-based
so you think about uh a gym you know you
boxingsport by a grocery store or
anchored by a CVS or something so I I
label it as more experience-based and I
do think that that's something our
municipalities need to lean into because
I know a lot of towns when they have uh
you know downtown Urban environment or
semi-urban environment they're
accommodating to mixed use uh but they
tend to want to preserve some retail on
the ground floor and I do think that
there is a retail aspect we just have to
slightly change our thought of retail it
could be a financial advisor that
invites members of the public in or
invites um you know an insurance agent
but we have to just think about parking
for those uh transient type uses where
I'm just dropping in to meet with my Tax
Advisor for a half hour heading out uh
so I hope that that answers the question
representative thank you representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman and this
is a little bit different question uh
what impact on sales or opportunities
for sales would be affected if an
additional El chip increase were
included to save New Hampshire's
historical
um so as far as inventory we need the
inventory in order to be able to make
those transfers to be able to have those
funds um so I think that's the bigger
inventory anybody yeses
op I don't want to um I don't want to in
any way dismiss the idea that regulation
in in many cases exclusionary zoning
those kinds of things are are not an
important aspect that need to be looked
at I will say I represent a community
and sit on the planning board we have no
comprehensive
zoning um the only requirements we have
are 50ft Road Frontage and a sufficient
lot size to accommodate a well and a
septic system unless you're on Town
Water and Sewer um I I I'm not sure we
could get any less restrictive than we
are we still have a very very serious
housing crisis in my town people are
fearing um you
know we had the conversation yesterday
and a lot of folks don't understand how
revaluation and the impact on their
property taxes works but they're scared
about
it and I just want to I just want to ask
you made the pitch for
regulation appreciate it um I appreciate
the study I heard two years ago when you
talked about the impact of Housing and
its impact on school costs and and that
they're not necessarily the boogeyman
that some folks think but I'm wondering
if there are other things you're looking
at one of the things in my community
we're concerned about and again it's a
function obviously of of housing costs
and people looking for shelter we have
probably three dozen or more um uh
individuals or families living in
um mobile
homes um whether they have sufficient
septic or not is
questionable um and we had a
conversation the other night about well
you know maybe we should start enforcing
the law which is only going to
exacerbate a situation where people
either end up
homeless uh or on the town W welfare
roles
or God knows what um so I'm I'm just
wondering if Beyond just
you know the lot size and and other U
easing of
regulations are there other
recommendations that that your
Association can come up with for example
in my community and I know my community
is not alone not not a unicorn in in the
state thank
you
do well certainly we were supportive of
um and I think that you had presentation
yesterday with the invest New Hampshire
funds and providing assistance um they
have some great stories in terms of
developments that were able to take
place by adding that sort of financing
uh in the stack so um certainly we're
that would be an opportunity um and in
terms of construction costs I know it's
challenging for anyone in this room to
have any impact but obviously higher
interest rates makes construction more
expensive um supplies become more
expensive and prohibitive sometimes for
folks who are looking to build um so
it's there's not a I think we've always
said there is not a silver bullet to
this it's going to take um a
multi-pronged approach in order to um in
start to increase inventory and bring
down those
prices and uh representative I just want
to also state I'm on the uh the board of
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
one of the other volunteer hats and one
of the things that I I've wrestled with
our staff and board have wrestled with
is how do you um how do you accommodate
a smaller scale project that may not
have the same economies of scale if
you're going to build a so-called litech
project low-income housing tax credit
project you need a scale of 40 plus
units to to build one on on you know
green dirt not a renovation project but
how can we make that barrier whether
it's litech or some other affordable
housing at a scale of 10 units or even
six right something that may be uh some
communities may not find as aggressive
but also um something that is still
economically viable for the developer
and I could just tell you you know
construction prices have remained a
challenge and so I think as Bob
mentioned any sort of stimulus as it
relates to invest NH or the affordable
housing fund um I can just say New
Hampshire housing is a is a great
Steward of those funds
follow um to that point Mr Norwood I'm
I'm wondering um
and scale is obviously an issue for for
a smaller Community like mine uh I'm
wondering are there uh Regional
approaches to that that might help solve
that problem are there examples of that
or is that a consideration yes I think
so Sarah you had a comment oh there are
um there are Regional uh outlets for
that so if you look at uh the the
patchwork of uh community action
programs that we have as as well as
for-profit and nonprofit developers yes
there are tools that we have uh but I
still think it's that um it's the riddle
of trying to get the economies a scale
on a 10 to 15 unit project how can we do
chairman okay I think uh do we have any
other questions if not we will proceed
to
lunch thank you very much thank you very
much thank you st time
all right so I'll see everybody back
here at 1 pm and we'll we have two more
two
e
if members would uh take their seats
okay the time being uh 104 we will get
started and uh first up is um New
Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute thank you all very much for
the opportunity to speak to you this
afternoon um my name is Phil lton I'm
the research director at the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute I'm
joined by my colleague Jess Williams
who's a policy Analyst at nhpi there are
seven of us at nfpi so please um feel
free to use us as information resources
we exist in part to um inform policy
makers and the public uh so uh please
make use of the resources that we have
available the information that we have
available you'll see in your folders
that um you have information about uh
the latest revenue report so the the
December revenues we wrote about that uh
in in an analysis that we published last
week we also um are putting to have put
together five fact sheets about issues
facing uh the New Hampshire economy and
granite Staters so you'll see housing
Health Child Care education cost of
living on all of those fact sheets and
we may refer to those over the course of
this presentation we at the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute were a
nonpartisan nonprofit independent policy
research organization we examine the
state budget state Revenue the state
economy and the economic security of
granite Staters particularly those of us
with low and moderate incomes in the
state and we were asked to come before
you today to talk about the New
Hampshire economy talk about how well
it's doing and also we're going to talk
a little bit about State revenues
because that's part of what the scope of
what we analyze as well and I know
certainly of interest to the ways and
means committees um at the discretion of
the chair we're happy to take questions
throughout we if we were to just run
through this presentation together it
would probably be about 40 minutes
without questions so we have a little
bit of time baked in for questions um so
folks have them especially if you have a
technical question about a a slide
please at the discretion of the chair we
don't mind being interrupted uh to
especially to explain a slide okay great
that sounds good thank you thank you
again for the opportunity um so we'll
start with a little bit about the
economy and while we focus on the New
Hampshire economy I did want to put up
one slide about the national economy you
already heard some this morning and some
yesterday about the state of the
National economy and it's broadly strong
one of the things that I think is pretty
remarkable is we've gone from a period
of high inflation following a period of
high job growth rebounding from after
the losses associated with the covid-19
pandemic to a lower level of inflation
while sustaining job growth throughout
this is the so-called soft Landing it's
pretty remarkable that this has happened
and in a way that has been um where we
still had economic growth sustained
through most of this period um and uh
the most recent data the December data
aren't on this graph but also we're
pretty substantial job growth inflation
is still a little bit higher though than
those Target rates we'll see where it
ends up in
20125 now moving on to the New Hampshire
economy this shows median household
income uh for so this is the middle
household in the middle of the income
distribution in New Hampshire adjusted
for inflation and note that the graph
starts at $50,000 so we've zoomed in so
you can see some of the variation over
time this is going back to 2005 so
before the Great Recession you can see
the pre Great Recession Peak if you
adjust for inflation was 2007 then it
took a long time for the losses
associated with the Great Recession the
losses in real income and spending power
to recover that was about a decade of of
time where spending power was either
lower or right about the same level for
the median household and then we we
didn't have data in 2020 unfortunately a
lot of people weren't answering surveys
and the Census Bureau was busy with
other things in 2020 um but we see a
much different recovery from the
covid-19 crisis which was a much
different recession right a much
different economic situation than we saw
in the Great Recession um but we saw
median household income actually go up
substantially relative to where it had
been prior to the covid-19 crisis then
it slipped in 2022 relative to inflation
right so median household income dropped
if you adjust for inflation between 2021
and 2022 and then went back up in 2023
to about where it was not quite if you
are pursing hairs but about where it was
in 2021 so that's a good sign right
that's that shows that unfortunately the
most recent data we have in this data
set is 2023 but that shows that the
spending power of households did
increase after being eroded by inflation
now that's the median household which
had about $997,000 in 2023 and that's
for all household sizes uh now um and by
the way the average household size in
New Hampshire is was in 2023 about 2.4
people um and that's a little lower than
the national household size the national
average for household size what about
the distribution of incomes around that
median so you can see on the pie chart
here that there's a pretty broad
distribution these are the um categories
of incomes that the Census Bureau gives
us with some uh combined to simplify the
graph but you can see almost 16% of
households had incomes at or above
$200,000 in 2023 about one in four New
Hampshire households had incomes below
$50,000 in those 2023 data and about 11%
had below
$25,000 in annual income in 2023 now
some of those households were probably
in poverty but just just give you a
sense of the poverty thresholds we'll
talk about poverty rates a little more
in this later in this presentation uh
the poverty threshold in 2023 for a
single person under 65 years old was a
little under
$166,000 in that year so um and that's
by the way that's a National Standard so
that's that poverty threshold is true
for all the contiguous 48 states right
that the official measure of poverty
doesn't adjust for regional variation
except for Alaska and Hawaii and for a
three person household with one child it
was a little under $225,000 so when we
think about the household compositions
for those households in that sort of
bottom 11% of incomes you know that
composition matters as to whether they
qualify as being in poverty or not now
what about personal income if we measure
personal income per capita so how much
household in individual income was there
in New Hampshire divided by the number
of people and adjusted for inflation um
so you can see on the graph here on the
right if we compare 2019 to 2022 which
is green or uh cross thatched uh the bar
or the and the solid bar is 2019 to 2023
and you can see here where the years
matter quite a bit right we saw in New
Hampshire more personal income growth
between 2022 and 2023 than some of our
neighboring states but overall relative
to 2019 personal income was behind in
terms of its growth rate this is not the
level this is the growth rate um uh from
2019 to 2023 so this shows you that the
years matter right the years definitely
matter where you're benchmarking where
you're starting but that we may have had
a little bit less income growth in New
Hampshire um uh across the pandemic than
we saw in some of our neighboring states
now expanding beyond the data that you
see in that graph if we look at some of
the patterns around New England because
I I want to unpack this a little bit
more for you uh New Hampshire in New
England had some pretty similar patterns
in terms of income growth if you look
back to 2018 and look through 2023 and
we don't have a full year data for 20124
yet but if you look at the first three
quarters of 2024 then our income growth
is pretty similar to what you see in New
England so we're not diverging
dramatically at least based on the
preliminary data we have thus far in
2024 now uh I've mentioned some of the
data limitations about what do we have
yet for 2024 or not some of the early
data that we do have for 2024 for the
first 11 months of it is about wages so
what you're seeing here is inflation
adjusted change in uh the average
private sector wage this is an average
not a median and uh this is preliminary
data for the first 11 months of 2024 and
you can see some patterns here that may
be similar to or may remind you of what
you saw in the median household income
graph where we saw that there were you
know some years um in in the last decade
where inflation uh did outpace uh the
average wage some years where it did not
outpace the average wage in 2020 you see
that big increase remember uh if you a
lot of individuals who had lower incomes
lost employment right so that means they
don't get calculated in their average in
the average wage uh for private sector
wages anymore so that's part of why we
see that substantial increase 2021
though we saw another increase 2022 we
saw average wages slip behind inflation
2023 again like the median household
income we saw more of a positive number
2024 we don't know yet because these are
still preliminary but it looks like we
might be slipping behind inflation again
um now I do want to note that um uh
director Golab did have a if I may
interrup representative thank you Mr
chair um one quick question how closely
does this slide track with
national so very good question I was
actually just where I was going so thank
you um the National Data that director
golob showed you yesterday um it was
interesting to see how much more wages
were appeared to be outpacing inflation
at the national level than at least
these preliminary New Hampshire data so
I don't know the reason for the
discrepancy these data could be revised
right you know the New Hampshire data
are based on fewer surveys right or
fewer
um data collection a smaller amount of
data collection from businesses right
because these are effectively um this is
from the current employment survey so
this is collected from businesses
themselves these could be revised when
the benchmarking process happens early
next year and that may bring us more in
line with what we see at the national
level but I was surprised to see that
difference between what we see
nationally and what we see in New
Hampshire is particularly given our
labor force constraint here thank you y
you're
welcome great um so let's look at the
distribution of wages across income
groups and again here we don't have data
for 2024 and because we're facing you
know limited data in some of these
surveys these are threeyear averages and
this is over a very long time Horizon so
what we're doing here is comparing the
2024 to 2026 average wage by percentile
to just before the pandemic 2017 to 2019
and the most recent data we have which
is 2021 to 2023 and the the value of
these data is it show shows you at a
more granular level what's happening
with wage growth at different parts of
the income scale so that 10th bar that
you see that 10th percentile that means
10% of wages hourly wages and this
includes all income from work were lower
than that 90% were higher and that's you
know you can track that across the scale
the 50th is the medium and interestingly
if you look at the uh green solid bars
which is comparing just before the Great
Recession to just before the covid-19
crisis we see that there was not really
wage growth across that time period
relative to inflation for the bottom
half of the income scale for median
income earners and Below however there
was wage growth at the higher end of the
income scale but then look at 2021 to
2023 and we can see where some of our
labor force constraint in the state
starts to play in because we saw much
faster wage growth in this recovery not
relative to the Great Recession recovery
we saw much faster wage growth at the
low end of the income scale and this is
real wages relative to inflation
right I do want to note this is a
three-year average so a lot of inflation
happened in 2022 so that's captured here
but a more granular breakdown if you
were to look at each individual Year may
tell a different story but on the on the
total scale on the overall scale where
we take these threeyear averages and
compare them which again gives us more
data stability this suggests that this
recovery has been stronger for
individuals with lower
incomes now what about across
geographies in New Hampshire here are
are 10 counties in the state arranged by
the highest inflation adjusted median
wage growth from 2019 to 2023 to the
lowest inflation adjusted median wage
growth and this is these are percentage
terms um so interestingly if you look
all the way over on the left the solid
bars show that wage change and that's
Coos Carrol chesher and bnap counties
right so some of our more rural counties
in the state um saw that higher
percentage growth in wages if you look
at the bars that are on uh also on the
graph with it with the um with the cross
thatch through them that shows the
change in the size of the labor force
now I want to be clear when we're
talking about these survey these data
we're talking about surveying households
and asking are you working or actively
looking for work right so this is people
who are unemployed but actively seeking
work or people who are employed could be
part-time could be full-time but they
have a job um and we can see that the
size of the labor force based on these
data went down across all 10 10 counties
if you compare 2019 to 2023 um but went
down faster in Coos Carol and chesher
County where we saw the faster wage
growth right so that has implications
for the economy in those counties and it
also is a function somewhat of supply
and demand right if you have a smaller
labor force fewer people in your
available pool of workers then you might
be seeing wages grow faster so that may
be what we're seeing
here now I know New Hampshire employment
security already covered some of these
data so I'm not going to spend very much
time on them I did try to put it in
graphical form for you and my apologies
for scrunching it all together here um
but uh I wanted to show where the way
where um job growth was between 2019 and
2023 by employment sector you can see
all the way over on the left
professional scientific and Technical
Services as you've already heard those
did quite well during the pandemic and
associated with the pandemic and then
Administration administrative support in
Waste Services construction and
wholesale trade we see increases in
those sectors on the other end we see
accommodation and Food Services
manufacturing total government and
Retail trade those have declined in
terms of their employment um I think I
think each one of these has a story
behind them and I don't know all the
stories behind them um but I would uh
venture to say that retail trade uh is
you know we see some of that being
affected by more people doing online
shopping more uh more Automation in the
retail experience and um and total
government uh there was an increase in
federal um but if I recall correctly
local was a a sign substantial negative
uh over this time
period now if we look broadly again
using those survey data asking people
are you employed and a resident of New
Hampshire and working or actively
seeking work this is where we can
measure how many people are are uh
comprising that unemployment rate in New
Hampshire right how many people are
unemployed and actively seeking work
this is going all the way back back to
2005 so we can see here the top line
with the triangles is the number of
people who say they're participating in
the labor force they're employed or
actively looking for work and then the
bottom line with the squares that is the
number of people who say I'm employed
they could be part-time and looking for
other work too but they are at least
employed in some fashion and you could
see the impacts of the Great Recession
and a period where we had a fair bit of
Labor Surplus in the state and then the
labor market became more constrained as
we approached the covid-19 pandemic 2020
is pretty clear on this graph as you can
see but since then one of the things
that gives me more optimism going into
2025 is that we have seen at least in
the preliminary data year to date in
2024 both in in this survey both
employment and the size of the labor
force increase whereas it hadn't in 2023
right so that's I I think a positive
sign going into 2025 if those data hold
through the benchmarking process uh the
um one thing I do want to note as well
if you ask
employers what how many jobs they've
filled in the state you actually get a
little bit of a different pattern right
now we're still below where we were pre
pandemic in 2019 and these data and this
is people who live in New Hampshire uh
and you're asking them are you working
so this could in include people who are
working out of state or who are working
for non- New Hampshire Employers in some
capacity right here uh we see that we
haven't quite recovered relative to
those pre-pandemic levels but if you ask
employers how many jobs do you have
filled then we have recovered right
which suggests there may be more
part-time jobs or more people who are
working in state as opposed to out of
state right so those are some of the
variables that it's important to
consider when you're looking at these
data because there are some U things
that may appear to be discrepancies but
they may have some explanation as
well if we look at the unemployment rate
one thing I should note too that shaded
area that's the number of people who are
unemployed right so that's about 20,000
people in the state currently who
comprise the unemployment rate what does
that unemployment rate look like if we
compare it on a macro scale the most
recent uh 12 month data that we have
both these measures for which ends in
June 2024 how does that compare to 2019
you can see in the solid bar the
unemployment rate is exactly the same
it's 2.6% right which is quite low um
and the other bar the Shaded one the
Shaded one um that has uh that is a
broader measure of unemployment so these
are folks who have looked for work and
in the last four weeks but look for work
in the last year um people who have been
are working parttime for economic
reasons and would prefer to be working
full-time um people who are available
for work but not actively seeking it we
can see that that unemployment rate is
higher right so that includes everyone
who's in the 2.6% that unemployment rate
is higher was higher in 2019 maybe a
little lower in the most recent data
that we have but you know still still
elevated but about 5% so that gives us
some sense of where there may be slack
in the labor force and this is the best
single number that I know of to
characterize the labor force constraint
in the state um the labor force shortage
in the state it is not a perfect number
um but what it measures is the number of
open positions in the state divided by
the number of unemployed workers meaning
the number of people who are actively
seeking work and have actively SE work
uh sought work in the last four weeks
you can see here that in the runup and
this goes back 25 years almost the state
a
um you can see uh in the runup to the
Great Recession there was about one job
opening for every unemployed worker that
dropped following the Great Recession in
the runup to the covid-19 crisis it was
almost two job openings for every
unemployed worker suggesting that a lot
of these jobs weren't being filled and
then we see a drop associated with the
pandemic and after that in uh especially
in early 2022 and early 2023 we see
three to three and a half job openings
for unemployed worker the at least
according to these data that's dropped
back back down to about two job openings
for every unemployed worker um so that
suggests that there's been some easing
in labor force constraint um I do
somewhat expect that to be temporary for
some of the reasons that Jess is going
to talk about in the next portion of the
presentation
great thank you um so I'll just be
talking a little bit about demographics
in the State uh as well as household
costs for families uh across New
Hampshire and how this imp impacts the
economy uh so while the state's
population has grown we know that growth
has been much smaller compared to
previous decades uh so from 2010 to 2024
the state's population grew by about 7%
comparatively we know that from 1980 to
1990 the population grew by about
25% uh the growth in the graph that you
see spanning from about 1960 to 2000 is
a period where the number of births uh
in the state tended to outpace the
number of deaths this was also a time
where a large number of people were
moving into the state due to the growing
Metropolitan Boston
area while the state's population has
grown uh we know that a greater number
of people have reached or will be
reaching traditional retirement age in
the coming decades as of July of 20123
about 20% of the state's population was
over the age of 65 um about 15% were
between the ages of 55 to 64 represented
in the orange bars on the graph and
comparatively uh while children under
the age of 18 represented about 18% of
the population we know that that number
has decreased you can see on the graph
that children under age 5 represent a
much smaller bar uh compared to that of
young adults as well as the working age
uh New Hampshire has historically relied
on immigration to grow its population
when we're talking about immigration
we're referring to both domestic
migration so people moving into New
Hampshire from other states across the
country as well as international
migration meaning people moving into New
Hampshire uh from other countries across
the globe you can see on the uh graph
that beginning in the couple of years uh
leading up to the pandemic population
growth became equally influenced by
domestic migration most notably in the
last couple of years in 2023 and
2024 represented in the green bars on
the graph um you can see that the number
of deaths in the state has consistently
outpaced the number of births at least
since 2017 so more simply put the
state's population would be declining
without this immigration to the
state uh so while New Hampshire has
relied on immigration we know that net
migration to the state has slowed um
when we think about people moving into
the state New Hampshire has consistently
gained population from other New England
states most predominantly from
neighboring Massachusetts uh we can see
that immigration from Massachusetts did
increase in 2021 and 2022 compared to
the two years prior to the pandemic this
is largely due to increases in remote
work as well as the possibility of more
people having the opportunity to move
into their second homes uh because of
that remote work when we think about
those moving out of the state we see
sort of the opposite effect occurring
with Maine uh you can see that more
people moved out to Maine during the
pandemic compared to the two years prior
uh during this time New Hampshire also
lost a net population to the South
Atlantic region being Florida and the
Carolinas um this is largely due to the
number of retirees who moved to the
region both um for warmer weather and
per
amenities uh so when we think about the
state's changing population in
constraints on the workforce we of
course have to consider uh the financial
constraints facing families across the
state so according to the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology's living wage
calculator the Statewide cost of living
for a family of three being two working
adults and one child was close to
$98,000 uh as of 2024 when we combine
housing and child care costs these two
expenses together make up nearly
onethird of household budgets across the
state you can also see that cost of
living varies quite a bit uh based on
location from about 105,000 in
Rockingham County to about 880,000 in
Coos County uh in addition to housing
and child's care included in these
estimates also include Transportation
medical costs food internet mobile uh
taxes and what they refer to as Civic
expenses this includes things like going
to museums uh participating in cultural
activities and other activities that
help stimulate the state's economy um
they also include the other bracket this
includes um purchasing households uh you
know Necessities clothing uh among other
things um needed for the household it's
important to note that not included in
these estimates are things like student
loan debt credit card debt as well as
any other emergency expenses that may
further constrain a household's
budget separate researchers at the
economic policy Institute found similar
costs of living for the state um
although the researchers use slightly
different criteria you can see that
housing child's care and transportation
make up the largest slices of the pie um
comparatively we can also see that
housing in Rockingham County is almost
double what it is in coas County uh for
both MIT and Epi estimates it's
important to note that these estimates
fall well above uh the federal poverty
guidelines as well as the actual incomes
of many Granite Staters in the state as
fell mentioned on the previous uh few
slides um I mentioned that housing is
one of the highest costs for families in
the state um as of June of 2024 the
median cost for purchase ing a single
family house in New Hampshire uh Rose to
a record high of $540,000 uh this was an
increase of about 71% from June 2019
before the pandemic prices do tend to
peak in the summer months so they have
come down a bit however when we look at
the median cost for purchasing a home
for all of
2024 uh that cost still fell above half
a million dollars um we know that
housing costs have also increased at a
faster rate compared to incomes and
wages in the state Based on data that we
have from New Hampshire employment
security the average hourly wage for New
Hampshire increased by about 41% from
2015 to 2024 uh comparatively you can
see that um the increase in housing cost
incre for purchasing a single family
house increased by about
and while prices have remained higher in
the Southeastern part of the state um
prices have risen risen much faster in
rural areas uh so from 2018 to 2024 the
median cost for purchasing a single
family house in the state increased by
about
82% uh you can see that the Southeastern
uh four counties all had percentages
around that state median however uh when
you look at the rest of the state all
counties experien price changes higher
than
90% um during this time the median price
of purchasing a single family house in
the State uh doubled or nearly doubled
counties um prices have also increased
for renters in the state so as of 2024
the median monthly price for a two
bedroom unit in New Hampshire uh
including both rent and utilities was
close to $1,800
uh an increase of about 36% from 2019
before the pandemic um housing prices in
the state are largely influenced by the
lack of housing inventory across New
Hampshire um according to New Hampshire
uh housing a 5% vacancy rate is
considered a balanced rental market for
the state um however you can see in the
graph that the state's vacancy rate has
consistently Fallen below that 5%
reaching record lows from 2020 1 to
2023 um it's also important to note that
Rising housing costs have likely
disproportionately impacted renters who
tend to make median incomes uh far below
that of a homeowner according to the US
Department of Housing and Urban
Development uh households paying more
than 30% of their incomes towards
housing costs are defined as cost
burdened um as of 2023 data more than
half of renters in the state met this
burdened uh in addition to Rising
housing costs the high price of child's
care has also impacted Granite State
families uh as of 2023 which is the most
recent set of data that we have
available the cost for an infant and
four-year-old and Center based care in
the state was nearly
$32,000 uh this was an increase from the
2022 according to the IAL poverty
measure around 98,000 Granite Staters uh
had incomes below the federal poverty
guidelines in 2023 as Phil mentioned
this was about
$25,000 um in 2023 for a family of three
while the state's overall poverty rate
has remained uh relatively the same at
about 7% we can see that um poverty
among older adults has been on a rise at
least since
2019 uh according to the official
measure poverty among children has
fluctuated every couple of years from
its um increase in
2012 however as of 2023 uh the state's
child poverty rate fell at around the
same as the state's overall poverty
rate while it is not a official
replacement for the official poverty
measure the supplemental poverty measure
can provide some more insights into
economic constraints for families in the
granite state uh unlike the official
measure the supplemental poverty measure
takes into account things like Regional
uh differences in costs of housing
child's care as well as factors in taxes
and tax credits you can see that based
on the supplemental poverty measure
poverty among children in the state was
was cut in half from 2019 to
2021 this is largely due to the increase
uh in federal aid to families during the
covid-19 pandemic most notably
expansions to the child tax credit in
2021 that expired uh in
2022 while both uh child's and older
adult poverty did increase in 2022 based
on this measure you can see that there
was a much more substantial increase
among poverty among older adults age 65
and
over and finally according to US Census
Bureau data uh from the first 9 months
of
2024 you can see that nearly one in
three New Hampshire adults reported a
difficulty affording usual household
expenses this was an increase from about
1 in4 uh adults in 2020 and 2021 again
largely due to the influx of Federal Aid
during the pandemic as well as lower
costs of living uh in 2020
2021 and with that I will turn it back
over to
Phil great thank you Jess um so I want
to take an opportunity because you are
the ways and means committees and also
interested members of the finance
committees um to talk a little bit about
State revenues and some of the recent
trends that we've seen in state revenues
in New Hampshire um so first I'm going
to show you a longtime Horizon this is
aggregate Revenue to the general and
education trust funds combined um going
back all the way to State fiscal year
2014 what is the year-over-year change
what is the most recent 12 months
average that's collected each month
compared to the prior 12 months average
so that's those are the metrics that
you're seeing here and you can see we've
actually we've had some variation over
this time period some substantial
variation first there was faster growth
uh following a pretty long slow recovery
from the Great Recession it took New
Hampshire a long time to sort of get the
economy back into gear so to speak after
the Great Recession and we saw that
economic activity really pick up in 2014
where we saw a faster growth rate in the
state's grow State product and that is
something that then we uh see in the tax
revenues in 2015 and 2016 and that was a
pretty broad-based increase in tax
revenues um then we see a much more
specific increase in tax revenues
following the um the federal tax cuts
and jobs act that passed in December
2017 we saw the repatriation of profits
from overseas really affecting the
business profits tax base and that is
that was a phenomenon where if you look
at how tax revenues grew broadly that
was very focused in the business taxes
particular Al as we'll see a little bit
later in the business profits tax um
specifically then you see a decline that
is some of those onetime revenues
associated with the tax cuts and jobs
act going away and the initial impacts
of the covid-19 pandemic which in the uh
fourth quarter of 2020 were pretty
profound in terms of how they impacted
Revenue how fourth quarter fiscal 2020 I
should say however then we see a really
significant increase in tax revenues
very as you can see historically very
significant that was driven largely by
the business profits tax but also by the
real estate transfer tax in a latent
fashion the meals and rentals tax a lot
of revenues did behave in ways that if
you had asked in April 2020 we wouldn't
have expected right um but since then
we've seen a decline and that decline
means that now we actually don't have
year-over-year growth we have a
year-over-year decline if you compare
the most recent 12 months to the prior
12 months what does that look like if
you aggregate over the course of years
go a little bit further back this goes
back to 2006 again General and education
trust fund revenues combined and
adjusted for inflation right so this is
based on inflation that consumers see in
the economy in the northeastern United
States how did revenues compare over
this time period you can see they do
bounce around this is not adjusting for
policy changes either right these are
just the revenues that were collected
and you know there were some years where
you saw in the Great Recession there was
an 8% drop in fiscal 2009 there was an
8% increase in fiscal 2016 again that
was that uh economy getting back into
gear after the Great Recession and you
see in 2021 a 16% increase relative to
fiscal 2020 uh then another increase in
fiscal 22 but since then we saw Revenue
slip and then essentially be flat at
least in the preliminary data that we
have so far for fiscal 24 because again
we don't have those un audited data as
my former boss at the office of
legislative budget assistant Mike Kane
told you very at the very beginning of
these uh of these briefings so when
we're looking tax revenue sourced by tax
revenue source and here are the uh here
are the top 10 with the with the two
business taxes combined into one line
the top 10 tax revenue sources in the
state if we compare the unaudited data
for State fiscal year 2024 to what we
have uh what we've SE saw in fiscal 23
combined business tax revenues were down
3.3% if you were to split these out
again as as uh commissioner step noted
we don't have the data yet to be able to
split these out cleanly those data are
quite delayed um and they because they
depend on those final tax returns being
filed and we don't know that yet for
fiscal 24 or all of fiscal 23 but if you
were to split them out the business
Enterprise tax would probably be about
fifth on this list um combined business
tax revenues were 3.3% down meals and
rentals tax revenues this is a sort of a
Workhorse Revenue source for the state
up
3.8% Statewide education property tax
this is set to raise $363 million in
statute every year except for fiscal 23
when it was set to raise 2 63 million so
this 38% increase that is all because of
statutory change right so that's not an
increase that is because of underlying
economic conditions this is a revenue
Source that's set to raise a certain
amount and that amount changed between
fiscal 23 and fiscal 24 the Medicaid
enhancement tax which is a tax that you
on the ways and means committees you
don't think about as much but it has a
very substantial role in offsetting
general fund expenditures so folks on
the finance committees will see the
effects of the Medicaid enhancement tax
funding more of the non-federal share of
Medicaid that was up about 6% um and
it's a really again was the fourth
largest tax revenue source that the
state had tobacco tax revenues were down
about 133% real estate transfer tax
revenues are down about 14% And that put
it below the interest in dividends tax
which was up actually 25% between fiscal
23 and fiscal 24 uh and that um is
likely due in large part to behavior in
the stock market dividends payments as
well as interest rates being higher
right with higher interest rates more
interest income is earned and then uh
motor fuels tax and insurance premium
tax we saw some slight growth now in
when we're thinking about surpluses and
deficits when we're thinking about state
revenue relative to the state revenue
plan state fiscal year 2023 ended with
what may be I think a record Surplus
right we were talking about more than
$500 million in Surplus where did that
come from and here you can see in this
pie chart the breakdown and composition
of the largest sources of state revenue
Rue Surplus in state fiscal year 2023
the combined business taxes meals and
rentals tax Lottery Commission revenues
which have been doing quite well um real
estate transfer tax insurance premium
tax interest and dividends and then all
other combined was still a $44 million
net positive okay fiscal 24 new state
revenue plan right so when we're talking
about Surplus and deficits that state
revenue plan matters what were the
largest sources of revenue Surplus same
colors but we have a much smaller
variety and a much smaller Surplus
overall right 126 million
and not more than 500 million the
interest in dividends tax brought in 48%
of that Surplus at about 615 million
over plan interest on state cash
Holdings brought in $64 million of that
Surplus these are both inherently
temporary Revenue sources because the
interest on state cash Holdings desend
depends on the state holding cash and
some of that cash is onetime federal
funds also depends on interest rates
which since fiscal year 24 have gone
down I don't know exactly what's going
to happen in fiscal 25 but or pardon me
in fiscal 26 and 27 but fiscal year 24
uh to now they've gone down and the
interest and dividends tax was repealed
as of January 1st you'll still get
revenue from it in in April you'll get
the tax returns and there'll probably be
some windup associated with it um but uh
the tax returns from 24 I should say but
this these are both inherently temporary
Revenue sources which means without
those there essentially wouldn't have
been a surplus in
24 so where are we now right where are
we as of the end of December um and
you'll see in your full fers we have
some deeper analysis of where December
revenues came in and if you look all the
way over on the left these are General
and education trust fund sources broken
out in more detail interest on surplus
funds and interest in dividends tax
revenue are still the leading
contributors to the revenue Surplus but
they are both lower as you can see in
the blue bars or the ones that have the
cross thatches on them they are both
lower than they were uh last state
fiscal year at this time so if you
compare this December to last December
year end and if you look it's a mixed
picture otherwise except for all the way
over toward the right I did put the
motor fuels tax on here as well even
though it's not a general and education
trust fund Revenue Source who wanted to
give you context towards the right you
can see combined business profits and
business Enterprise tax revenue is about
83 to 84 million below where it was last
year at this time and where it was
relative to plan right so both those
measures it's sort of coincidence that
they're that close to each other in
number but both those measures show that
we're not collecting as much business
tax revenue um as we did last year or as
we expected to do when the legislature
set forth the state revenue plan amounts
in June of
23 now a lot of the revenue growth that
we've seen over the last eight years in
particular has been because of business
tax revenues particularly business
profits tax revenues remember how I
talked about it was difficult to break
out the BPT from the BET revenues well
the Department of Revenue Administration
Endeavors to do it every year in their
annual reports and provide us with those
draft data um however it's you know it
we we just got the data from tax year
2022 right in the in the uh annual
report that was released a few months
ago so here's the breakdown from 2008 to
2022 you can see that Top Line in uh
with the diamonds in blue that's the
business profits tax revenue so that's
gone up much more substantially um and
that is uh we'll talk about some of the
factors for that business Enterprise tax
revenue has been much more tepid much
there has been growth but it's been
flatter that's in part because of the uh
difference in the tax base you know it's
largely compensation um and it tracks
quite well to compensation paid in the
state which we know through the state's
unemployment compensation system but the
rate reductions have been as a
percentage of the original rate in 2015
much more aggressive for the business
Enterprise tax than they have been for
the business profits tax and that has
cost revenue and that is something that
we see in each one of these years that
Revenue breaks from the trend of the tax
base um in each of the uh in each of the
years where there's a tax rate reduction
but what about the business profits tax
why do we see that increase we see that
National corporate profits have
increased substantially particularly
since the start of the covid-19 pandemic
from 2016 to 2019 they were growing
pretty well you see the pandemic
interrupted it but then there was a very
substantial growth particularly in 2021
and 2022 which matches some of those
Revenue increases that we see and
National corporate profits do matter for
the corporate tax base in New Hampshire
because if we look at the breakdown of
filers and how much each filer pays
about 19 well filers in the draft data
that we have so far for tax year 2022
paid 40% of the business profits tax
right this is not including the business
Enterprise tax that's a more distributed
picture and the business Enterprise tax
is used as a credit against the business
profits tax but we can see that those
top nearly 120 filers combined with the
next thousand or so filers so think
about the top a little less than 1200
filers paid 3/4 of the state's largest
tax revenue Source right and and
corporate tax revenues if you look at
State corporate taxes Across the Nation
tend to be relatively volatile right
that is one of the more volatile tax
revenue sources so these this is part of
the reason why we can look at those
National corporate profits and when
you're doing Revenue estimates thinking
about those National corporate profits
May provide you with some additional
Insight another way that we can know
that those National corporate profits
matter is the types of filers what do
entities file as What do businesses file
as when they're paying their business
profits tax um here you can see
Proprietors including so Proprietors and
corpor ation and those two different
shades of blue Partnerships fiduciaries
or a small portion and then those Waters
Edge combined multicomponent filers what
that what that effectively means is that
you have a business entity that has at
least one at least two different parts
to it right it could be a proprietorship
and a corporation or it could be two
different corporations that are
Incorporated in different states for
example they're providing a combined
report and that combined report would
show up as a Water's Edge or combined
report rep in Filer and they were 7% of
the filers if you look at the revenue
from tax year 2022 they were 58% of the
revenue collected right so that suggests
and commissioner stepp referred to these
as multinational entities right um there
could be a Waters Edge filer that's
Incorporated in New Hampshire right or
that's based in New Hampshire there
could be a Waters Edge filer elsewhere
right there could be a corporation
that's based entirely outside New
Hampshire and does business here has
sales here and as a result files tax
here right so there's a um uh this
doesn't say where they are headquartered
this doesn't say where they're based but
it does say that the complex entities
that have multiple components make up
the majority of the revenue that comes
into to the state's largest tax revenue
source and largest tax revenue Source by
a factor of two and one of the reasons
we can look at National corporate
profits and S and we have an
understanding that that is probably
affecting our tax base as well is that
if we look at where State corporate tax
revenues have trended overall since 2015
so between 2015 and 2023 we see that
Nationwide they've almost tripled over
that time period And if you take New
Hampshire out of New England they've
gone up 172% New Hampshire has went up
124% so a little bit lower policy
changes were probably part of that we
did have a lot of policy changes
associated with the business taxes both
the rate and the base over this time
period um but the growth that we see in
corporate tax revenues is a national
phenomenon right and this shows that
that all states or all states in
aggregate I should say have seen
increases in their corporate tax
receipts so what are some takeaways
after we've spoken at you for about 40
minutes here um one is that the economy
is performing well overall and income
growth may be more limited in 2024 uh
relative to inflation compared to 2023
so we'll have to see uh what that looks
like um as we get more finalized data
about 98 ,000 Granite Staters have
poverty level incomes and poverty may be
rising among older adults in the state
we have two different sets of poverty
related data that point to that nearly
one in three adults reported difficulty
affording usual household expenses
that's that 30% number that Jess
referred to and there are the key cost
increases that we see in housing in
child care um and the accessibility and
affordability of those are taking up
more of household budgets and that
restricts those households abilities to
spend money in other parts of the
economy right so that has implications
for economic growth and prosperity um
there are two of the key factors holding
back growth in the labor force and the
economy um the third being long-term
demographic Trends as Jess outlined and
as you heard from uh Professor Johnson
and you heard from the folks at New
Hampshire employment security it's uh
thematically important here um migration
has supported population growth and if
we're thinking about upskilling the
workforce making the most of all the
workforce that we have here education is
a long-term uh component of that as well
well when we think about people who are
we need people to be able to move here
and we need uh them to have the skills
to participate in the uh in the labor
force and in the economy State revenues
are declining overall both due to
external factors such as corporate
profits and interest rates and policy
choices that have reduced state revenue
the repeal of the interest and dividends
tax is a pretty significant component of
general fund revenues it was 8.8% based
on the fiscal year 2024 revenues we have
so far of general fund revenues that
shows up in the or that will show up in
revenues when we're comparing them
year-over-year next year for example um
and the economy and state revenues are
subject to considerable uncertainty over
the next two years it's a wide variety
of factors National Economic Policy
related Geo uh geopolitical factors um
Brian went through these on his or some
of these on his slide um it's not as
difficult a time I don't think to
project revenues as for example when you
were all sitting here in early 2021 um
but I do think there's a lot of
uncertainty going into to the next uh
two fiscal years um as we look at the
time Horizon for the next state budget
there are some additional resources that
you can find on our website and we're
happy to take any questions at the
discretion of the chair with the balance
of the
questions oh we got one representative
Daniels the first couple of slides when
you talked about personal can you come
up uh representative Daniels come up to
the microphone on the uh by the
door no the he can come over to this
microphone
sure I've been told that people watching
online can't hear us if we're not on a
mic yes as as someone who's watching
online earlier I I appreciate that thank
you thank you in regards to the first
couple of slides you talked about
personal income was that personal income
earned income or earned and unearned
earned income yeah great question uh
this is earn this is earned income and
income collected from sources other than
right so this is all income that's going
to households thank you I guess I have a
question um two of the larger uh groups
in the state are the um I think I don't
know if was your presentation or another
one
um whatever it was 34 to 55 year olds or
whatever and then the 60 plus now have
we seen a change in the 60 plus as to
the number of them that are continuing
to work um as opposed to just retiring
yeah so a great question um I'd say over
multiple decades we see that the 55 Pard
me the 65 to 74 age group we've seen an
increase in the labor force
participation rate it's still much lower
than the 55 to 64 age group you're
talking about going from you know 75 or
80% down to 30% um but it used to be
more like 20% so that's a that's you
know comparing the early 1990s to now
for example um in the post pandemic era
um and I haven't seen the latest data
from New Hampshire employment security
they have access to data that is not
published as regular ly but in the
post-pandemic era um we have seen some
swings in the labor force participation
among older adults uh there were more
older adults who took themselves out of
the labor force and some of them have
returned I don't know if that return has
been complete yet so to speak um and uh
and of course as the age profile changes
we're talking about different numbers of
people who are in that uh 65 to 74
category but over the long term yes the
labor force participation rate um has
increased for the 65 to 74 age group and
that's something that um I always when
we talk about demographics I always try
to remind folks is that you know when we
hit age 65 not everyone just suddenly
retires right there's there's a lot of
people who continue to work whether they
want to or need to right and whatever
the reason for it there are a lot of
people who are continuing to work uh and
uh that's something that I expect we'll
see more of as more of us reach that 65
to 74 age group it's a question of you
know does that labor force participation
rate move enough
that we don't see that the economic
impacts are sort of um affected by that
muns thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm on one of
your slides it was the slide that's
titled Revenue growth elusive in uh
fiscal year
2025 um the the um the difference in
combin business profits and Enterprise
tax um versus last year and also versus
the plan for last year were almost
identical numbers almost identical which
to me suggests that maybe there was
something that was missed in the in the
development of the plan last time do you
do you do you have any thoughts on that
well if we think about the factors that
have probably led to the revenue decline
relative to the plan um some of them are
quite complex some of them are some of
them are that we see different behavior
in corporate profits right so that's
hard to predict it's inherently hard to
predict um some of it is uh something
that uh the house ways and me committee
and the Senate ways Comm committee have
already addressed to a certain extent
which is the cap on uh Car Credit carry
forward so that credit carryover cap of
500% that originally was going to go to
250% for tax year 2025 and now has been
pushed out to 2029 we saw after the
implementation of that and I'll point to
in your green folders this is discussed
in that analysis of December revenues um
we saw an increase in refunds associated
with that and I think that I I suspect
that that was a hard thing to predict
the exact impact of going into this next
budget cycle we didn't you know we
didn't know exactly what the impacts of
that were going to be um because uh I I
I'll say frankly I was a little
surprised that the impacts were as
substantial as they were with that 500%
cap right I thought that would be um
high enough that not many business
entities would have actually been
hitting it never mind enough to reduce
revenues by as much as they were
relative to what we might have expected
just with underlying Trends um I I so
the business tax rate reduction there
was another tax rate reduction in the
business profits tax in 2023 that
wouldn't have affected revenues relative
to plan might have affect might be
affecting revenues relative to the prior
year but that's baked into the plan
right there's a static Revenue reduction
that's baked into the state revenue plan
from that um
another couple factors that are policy
changes that I think are hard to unpack
and hard to predict are the shift to
market-based sourcing and the shift to
single sales factor and that shift to
single sales factor in particular you
know what the extent to which it
increases or de decreases revenues I'll
leave to the folks at the Department of
Revenue Administration to be able to
speak to more comprehensively than I can
but it likely makes tax revenues more
volatile because before T the tax base
included Personnel property and sales
and the fraction of a multi-states
entity person Personnel property and
sales that were based in the state
shifting to just sales and sales were
double weighted before but shifting to
just sales means that the tax base may
move more rapidly for a business entity
then it would have if personnel and
property which might move a little bit
more slowly than sales changes um uh
that you know that change means that
there may be a little bit more
volatility that's been harder to predict
so uh
not a simple answer to your question
there's a lot to unpack and I think that
rather than thinking about did the state
revenue plan you know properly capture
all of that I think it's was just very
difficult to get at what the changes are
likely to be um uh when crafting the
state revenue plan because so many
policy changes have happened at the same
time recently um one other piece is just
that you know while we're seeing the
economy settle out much more now there's
still you we still have gone through a
period where we've seen quite a bit of
economic volatility by a number of key
metrics I say metrics cuz we're
researchers so that's what we look at um
but uh you know I think that saying that
the economy is completely settled now at
this point and we should expect it to
just be you know go forward as it did in
2018 and 2019 I we we've it's taken a
long time to work a lot of the things
out that were associated with the
disruptions in 2020 and 2021 so we may
still be seeing in the revenue declines
some of the effects of that right we may
be seeing profits get back to you know
something that's more of a normal share
of overall revenues or GDP um but I
don't I don't know it's a good set of
questions to to be asking thank you
thank you representative
M yeah thank you I have a followup
question to the 65 plus demographic can
you characterize uh how many people in
that demographic are Ting the workforce
then how long they stay in the workforce
before they move on to other things yeah
that's a a great question so um just you
want me to go ahead and take this one
okay um so uh the labor force
participation rate for at least for 65
to 74 like I said I think I remember it
being about 30% um and it may be in the
low 30s now maybe in the high 20s now uh
New Hampshire employment security does
have those data uh and the uh in terms
of when you get to
75 to 79 and 80 to 84 then you see
steeper declines in labor force
participation rate they it is measurable
right but we're talking more of like
single digits or very low double digits
at that point um in terms of how long
people stay in the labor force you know
that those data give you a sense of the
sweep of sweep of someone's life but in
terms of do people come and go from the
labor force you know doing a smaller job
or a job more temporarily um maybe they
take themselves out of Labor Force
because they've you know earned what
they're looking to earn in that time
period or for a health reason whatever
it may be I don't have those data on
that churn if that's what you were
asking but the labor force participation
rate again is you know it's pretty
significant especially when we're
talking about as a fraction of our
population in the state all yes thank
you yeah the reason for my question is
if we're thinking about young people
entering the workforce we assume it's
going to be a fairly decades long uh
contribution to the economy but we're
thinking about retirees entering the
workforce uh it looks like we have a
much shorter window for that so that's
why I'm trying to get a feeling for what
that likely contribution would be per
retiree compared to a younger
person and I I guess I'll say that um
you know for businesses and for
businesses and the state RIT large um
there are ways that work can be
structured that may make it more
amenable to individuals who are you know
in their 60s or in in their late 60s or
in their uh throughout their 70s and you
know some of those structures you know
there may be more more remote work or
Flex hours associated with that there
may be more you know either either uh
consultation or oversight uh roles
associated with that for you know for
folks who manage businesses I'm sure
they're thinking about this i' hope that
some of them are thinking about this
every day um I think that there are ways
that work could be structured and ways
that the state might seek to enable work
to be structured that would make it more
accessible for more folks and that's not
just older folks but individuals with
disabilities individuals who may um be
trying to piece together their Child
Care Solutions right so it's not just
older adults but as the data show older
adults are definitely going to become a
significant part of uh our labor force
consideration as more than 200,000 of us
who are between 55 and 64 in the next 10
years will be entering those traditional
retirement
Brun thank you very much Mr chair my
question uh Phil uh pertains to your
slide on wage growth and it's uneven
across counties and I notice the two
counties with the biggest change uh Coos
and Carol are more isolated from other
states do you have any breakout on the
data by uh if if that growth is by
instate employers or out of state
employers uh great question so um what
you see here the the wage growth that's
reported here um this is from o ews so I
can check to see uh how I believe this
is reported by employers who are based
in the counties but I'll I'll confirm
that for you um this is not uh this
these survey data are not the other
survey data that we're asking about
Labor Force participation it's a
separate survey from that so um this uh
this may better reflect what the wages
are that are actually paid by Employers
in the county um there are other data
that will get exactly to that or what
what is the average wage and what is the
change in the average wage over time of
employer of what employers pay who are
based in the county which I think is
what you're asking as opposed to like
remote work and that sort of thing yeah
yes followup yeah that's true and I'm
also curious to see particularly in the
counties that saw lower wage uh increase
are they employed out of state uh you
know um you know in southern Hillsboro
County even well all of Hillsboro County
we have a lot of people that commute
into Massachusetts I was just wondering
if these numbers reflect those those
people yeah so if I recall correctly
these numbers reflect uh what Employers
in the state are paying so it could be
some people who are out of state who are
working in New Hampshire who may be
reflected in these numbers as well um
but I'll confirm that for you I want to
make sure I'm I'm uh trying to remember
the process for the oew data collection
and uh whether there should be any
caveats that I'm layering in that I'm
forgetting so I I I want to check and
make sure but uh these these data are
not um uh just the surveying of the
population like we do for the labor
force statistics right like we did for
the uh like we do for the blue bars that
are on this graph the greenen bars on
this graph are a different data source
okay thank you very much you're welc uh
given that we're basically out of time
I'll take one more question from
representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking this
question uh concerning sales factor and
market-based sourcing
uh was there a complete study done
before these were implemented and
changing over from what we were doing in
the past
so I had seen an analysis of at least
single sales factor and I'm trying to
remember if Market based sourcing was in
it um from the Department Revenue
Administration and my understanding is
that um it's my understanding from
someone in this room that there was a
follow-up analysis that was done by
Department of Revenue Administration I
don't have direct access to those now
they probably live somewhere on dr's
website Dr is a wonderful state agency
so I'm sure they're being transparent
with uh uh with posting their reports um
uh I imagine commissioner step would be
able to offer you considerably more
insight than I could I know that we
didn't do that analysis at nfpi we
wouldn't have the data based on what's
publicly available to be able to do that
analysis thank you Phil and Jessica this
is very helpful thank you very much and
one more thing I do want to mention is
that um all of you who are legislators
should have had one of these mailed to
you I'm hoping that that arrived uh in
the last week um it's our resource that
really we try to break down data and
information about some of the key issues
facing the state including housing
including education
um and explaining the um the state
budget process and there's a chapter
towards the end about uh it's called
funding Public Services about state
revenue collections for those of you on
the ways and means committees those
might be of particular interest so thank
you very much Mr chairman for that quick
plug I wanted to make sure that you
didn't lose this in your mail it should
have arrived recently thank you right
thank
you okay and uh last but not least we
have Andrew kleene from the uh Josiah
right I'm sorry we'll try to keep this
right
here uh Jen just ref refresh my memory
we have two handouts but just the color
one okay but it's but it's one packet
yeah
okay
yes um representative only that should
be the entire packet the one you have
right there but Jen's got a ones um so I
I made an elementary school error I
didn't initially bring enough copies for
everybody so um I had misunderstood and
thought they would be printed out backck
not that I would bring them so that my
done all right well that's mine so you
can scrumble it on the top there um all
right so I'm Drew Klein I'm president of
the Josiah barlot Center for Public
Policy we're New Hampshire's free market
think tank we are like uh nfpi we're a
501c3 um private nonpartisan uh
independent research
organization
slides we do all right apologize for the
confusion there uh before we get to the
slides though since this is really sort
of a a look
forward um you know we don't make
economic projections but I thought it
might be sort of valuable to give you
guys a little bit of the barlet center's
take on looking at the economic um
situation going forward in the next
couple of years based on National policy
considerations and state policy
considerations and I want to start with
the national and I think you'll actually
find a lot of overlap uh with what we
view as either good policies or bad
policies that might affect New
Hampshire's revenues going forward with
some of the other presenters that have
presented over the last couple of days
um we look at
a B basically four things we're keeping
our eye on at the federal level when it
comes to policy changes this year and
I'll quickly go through them just so you
know where we're thinking and how you
might think about it if you see these
policies happen or not happen um and
what you might expect for an economic
impact the first is tariffs um our
position that high tariffs uh would be
very bad for New Hampshire uh
particularly a 25% tariff on Canadian
Imports would be very bad for New
Hampshire's economy um not to mention
the national economy I mean just not
only is Canada New Hampshire's number
one trading partner uh and not only do
tariffs raise prices for goods and
services that are imported um complete
they also tend to raise prices for
domestic manufacturers as well because
domestic manufacturers import a lot of
their components that they then assemble
in the United States um also something
that I think has gone unremarked a lot
on the Tariff situation is that the
United States still Imports a lot of
crude oil and about 60% of the crude oil
that we import comes from Canada so
Canadian tariffs would would be quite
bad uh for the national economy and then
for New Hampshire's economy that's the
first one the second is immigration um
our position is that the United States
does need to secure its border get rid
of the chaos have an orderly legal
immigration process all that stuff is
true but as you've seen from other
presenters New Hampshire um really
benefits a lot from immigration into the
state from both immigration from um
domestic ically from other states but
also immigration from foreign sources so
anything that would um again we're not
in favor of illegal immigration and that
has to be taken care of but depending on
how constraining and how severe certain
policies are um if it results in a
uh decreasing flow of people moving to
New Hampshire who have the skills want
to work and are capable of working um
that could impact our economy so third
is tax policy you've heard multiple
times over the last two days that New
Hampshire's business profits tax
revenues saw a big spike around the same
time that we uh federal government pass
the 2017 tax cuts those are up for
extension if they are not extended then
we would expect to see a pretty negative
impact on New Hampshire corporate
revenues if they are that would be a
good thing and the fourth is energy
policy again this doesn't get talked
about a lot but um there is a change in
I think attitude and Approach at the
very least between the current
Administration the incoming
Administration and the outgoing
Administration on energy policy ISO New
England has warned for years that New
England has a supply constraint problem
for fuel we don't have enough capacity
um for fuel particularly for natural gas
so energy policy at the federal level
that that would be less constraining on
transport and the construction of
Transportation of natural gas would be
very beneficial to New Hampshire that's
another thing that we're looking at um
not to mention State policies someone I
think earlier today mentioned the
Mid-Atlantic states that block pipelines
and stuff if we don't expect that to
change but if something were to change
and we could get more access to cheaper
fuel sources that would be helpful for
ANH economy so those are some things
outside of our control that we're just
keeping an eye on to sort of see whether
we can expect some changes in New
Hampshire's economy from those um before
we get into what we're looking at
policy-wise in New Hampshire I want to
share with you and this is where our
charts begin sort of how we got here so
this first chart is not adjusted for
inflation I just want to flag that um
but business tax revenue in 2015 versus
2023 so you can see the raw numbers it's
about 124% increase before you adjust
for inflation um if you adjusted that
2015 number to 2023 prices I think it'd
be about
$715 million so you can see it it would
be smaller but we'd still have a big
increase in business profits tax
revenues or business tax revenues that's
business taxes in general um our next
chart shows business tax revenue as a
share of the general education trust
fund budget in 2015 business tax revenue
was 25% of those funds by 2023 it was
39%
it's major
increase our next
chart the blue is business tax revenue
by year and the green is general
education
spending so you can see where the
revenues kind of track spending until
they
don't
um go to the next chart this is
something that would you be willing to
take questions yeah of course anybody
have questions now I'm represent B me
yeah yeah I was just wondering when
you're looking at you're using
2015 yeah that was before we finally
grew to the same level that the rest of
the country grew in
2016 on since the after the Great
Recession the the amount
of
um Revenue that we had or rather I'm
trying to remember I think it was uh GD
um State domestic product the amount of
State domestic product we had in
2016 reached the same level that it was
in every other state that gotcha I see
growth that they had that the every
other state had reached much earlier
because our tax system does that sure
well I mean we could have started at
2016 um it wouldn't change the numbers
that much we did 2015 just to show what
it was fairly substantially I don't
think it would change it that much uh
the growth wouldn't I mean we could do
that if we could update them it wouldn't
be much for me to go back and change the
start year to 2016 the reason we did
2015 was just to take a look at starting
right before the um business tax cuts
took effect so Ian that was the reason
to get that number in there well they
actually took well yes they took effect
for the
businesses in
2016 but in 2017 is when we saw the
money right so we wanted to go back
before that and just sort of see what it
looked
like but again we can change the start
year it would change the growth a little
bit but probably not that much it was a
fair bump between 14 and
15 I'm in 15 representative
WS thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question sure uh am I
understanding this that in this very
first chart here that uh as New
Hampshire has cut their uh business
taxes and taxes in general that we've
actually grown the revenue uh by quite a
lot yes and and that'sjust adjusted for
inflation this is not adjusted for
inflation as I said in the beginning but
if you did it would still be um and I
didn't make that adjustment so I could
go back and do that but if you did I'd
be somewhere in that just under $500
million range would be what you would
have left over after the inflation
adjustment so would still be a
substantial increase in Revenue yes I
did catch that thank you very
much yes represent El me thank you on
inflation and a incredible amount of
federal
subsidy no ma'am these are these are St
tax cuts and job these are State
business tax revenues not not federal
subsidies no but they they went into our
businesses and were productively used oh
okay any other questions on
that okay um so the next one
is I think it's a mistake um generally
to talk about revenues without talking
about spending um you've heard a ton
about revenues over the last couple of
days but not a lot of spending
information
so we tracked again 2015 to
2023 the increase in revenues and
spending and you can see total state
revenue in the in the blue line spending
in the red line they track really really
closely if you just do a straight line
um inflation is the orange
line and then the green just for context
is the business tax revenue so that
doesn't that we even out the year to
year fluctuation just doing the two
points so you can see that the growth
rate there
um now the next
chart so I think the big takeaway from
this chart is spending and revenue grew
a lot higher than the inflation rate
did so if you go to the next
chart this is spending versus revenue
and I like this one because I I want you
to pay attention to the diamonds in here
so what we see in New Hampshire is
pretty typical for a lot of
states the spending um the revenue will
it's as you've heard and you guys all
know the ones who've been around like
it's not a constant thing revenues
fluctuate um so it'll go up it'll come
down it'll go up but when it goes up
spending goes up to match it so this
is what we see if you if you look every
annually and you look at the budgets
spending is adjusted upward to match
revenues constantly and so that's just
the reality that that we live in and B
Center we look at both sides of the coin
spending and revenues it's not just one
side so you can see here the 2022 to
2023 um and we're still waiting for the
state audited 24 numbers that's why
they're on in you can see this Spike of
spending surpassing revenues here and
that's how we got to the situation we're
in right
now yep question question yes
representative ORS thank you Mr chair
and thank you G um so just backing up to
the business taxes where uh it was the
second chart yeah as a share so yes
share of the uh General and education
trust fund Revenue right so am I
understanding this right that even
though we've cut taxes we've increased
the funding from 25% to
39% for Education no so as general if
you take general education trust fund
Revenue entirely
businesses now pay a much larger share
than they did in 2015 they pay 39% of
that pool of money now so so they
shoulder a much larger share of that
Revenue than they used to
followup oh okay thank you so okay I got
that so we've increased the revenue for
that revenue's gone up correct yes and
uh in the in the previous slide to that
it looks like our spending on education
in general cost go along with this last
chart that we're exceeding our Revenue
continuously uh Revenue put it this way
spending always adjusts upward to match
Revenue that's how I put when you just
look at the way it works in this one
here that's the pattern you have the
revenue go up it kind of levels off but
the spending goes up to match the
revenue every time Revenue Rises so how
do we break the cycle spend less
thank
you I mean you can't um you know New
Hampshire does not have you have to have
a balanced budget in New Hampshire but
um A legislature cannot bind a future
legislature so you can't pass a law to
say well the future legislature can only
spend at the rate of population growth
and in and inflation like that would be
a general way to do it but you guys
can't do that unless you were to pass a
constitutional
amendment representa elberger thank you
Mr chairman yes uh I'm just wondering
whether you see this state spending
versus Revenue
uh uh behavior on the state part is any
different from what most people do in
terms of their
income typically when people earn more
you um representative Ford did you have
a question your light is your speak
speak is on
oh represent
Aly how do you decide whether the
spending went up first or the revenue
went up first well the spending can't
when did all of this
start that's a great question actually
um
so this is just how the process works
right so you guys on this committee are
in charge of the revenue and if you go
back through the years like the the
budget is written starting with the
governor and then the house and then the
Senate based on the revenues so just in
terms of the legislative process and how
it works the revenues come in you see
what you have and then you base your
spending on the revenues that are here
plus projections in the future so that's
how it works so in that just the way the
process works the revenue comes first in
New Hampshire typically that's how it
works follow up yes but the part of it
that is most extreme is when we were
using Revenue that came from the
pandemic uh from the uh arpa and its
successors on we had a great deal of
money pumped into our economy that was
not from us it was from the
feds and that increased I presume that's
in the our spending numbers so um these
are just general and education trust
funds number so they do not include any
federal grants any arpa money or any of
that this is just State money from State
revenues
okay okay we can continue okay um let's
go on to the next slide
so this will start our discussion of uh
so that that sort of gets where we are
now how we got to where we are now
there's a spending side there's a
revenue side so as legislators you have
to look at
both so we look at um for the B Center's
point of view we do look at um policies
in New Hampshire that might improve the
economy improve revenues um so I'll
start with some of the policies that
Hampshire this year some of the stuff
that we're talking about that might have
an impact on the economy and on
revenues so first which I won't get into
too many details because you guys have
heard this a lot in the last couple days
is housing this is a chart that I made
um going back to
1994 at the time I made this this is
that's the only data I had but
I we have others um going back
farther this is census data for building
permits the state has its own building
permit data which is slightly different
because the state has access to
different numbers than the census does
but um I checked with them to see if
it's okay to use this and they said yeah
it tracks pretty much with ours in terms
of the
pattern over time and what you'll see is
if you go back to
1994 the green line is single family
residential building permits the blue
line is multif family residential
building permits and you can
see they sometimes track with the
economy right um but you can look at
where we are now the end of
23 now again this doesn't include 2024
um because the state the publish data is
only through 23 now um we're not
building anywhere near what we we were
20 years
ago but it's worse than that so I
haven't had time to do that I'm going to
expand this chart at some point back to
the late 1960s but that just takes a lot
of time to do the data entry but I got
the
data and just to give you an example of
how out of whack our housing uh
construction is in New Hampshire in
1973 so we go back 50 years from from
um New Hampshire's popular was according
to the census 791 th000 in that year
developers received building permits for
4554 single family
homes and
3,179 multif family
units in
2023 New Hampshire's population was 1.4
billion
so yeah million sorry um big increase
like a 56% increase um
that's 1.4 billion people no I'm
kidding um typos are
terrible uh so that your developers
receive building permits for
2,996 single family housing units and,
1500 multif family units so in other
words in 50
years with about 56% of our current
population 50 years ago they were
building about half about 50% more
single SLE family homes and more than
double as many multif family units as
we're building
now and 1973 was the beginning of the
end of 73 was the beginning of the oil
embargo uh recession so um if you look
at 1974 which was full in the recession
um they were still building more than we
were building in 22 so that's how far
behind we are at permitting new
residential units and Josiah Barlett
Center I'm sure some of you familiar
with us we did a study in 2021 trying to
determine why New Hampshire was building
so many fewer um uh residential units
and um our inescapable conclusion was it
was local housing regulations so I won't
get into all that you guys know pretty
much that by this point but um the
takeaway for us is
that these regulations there are some
regulations at the state level too that
are getting in the way um Governor A's
right to point out that we have some
ecomic and environmental regulations
that are getting in the way and making
it more difficult but um a lot of it's
at the local level New Hampshire is an
outlier and the rest of the nation uh we
are much much much more restrictive on
residential construction than most
States and the United States is much
more restrictive than the rest of the
world um for these which makes New
Hampshire one of the most restrictive
places in the world for home building
and we're supposed to be the Live Free
or Die State the result of this is that
we don't actually have a market a
functioning um Residential Building
Market it's constrained by government
imp poos constraints so our position is
we need to remove some of those
constraints roll them back um to create
a functioning market and that would if
we can succeed in doing some of that
this year that would have a a good
economy so is there a question represent
elmy sure
uh I just wanted
to um I don't think that the residential
permits are ever corrected for the ones
that were not
used and um about I
forget about six years ago now we had
2,000 residential permits in
Lebanon and um uh units not permits
units permitted sure uh and two years
two years later there was 1,000 being
built
right well I mean that would I think
sort of underscore our point that you
know even the ones so we have a problem
with getting the permits in the first
place and even when you get a permit
some Builders don't go through with it
because they can't get the financing or
they run into other problems so the
numbers for homes that are actually be
built or even smaller than the permits
which is even more alarming
but uh yeah follow up I would like to
just caution you that some of those
environmental
requirements uh we have a lot of land
that gets
severely uh flooded in Lebanon and we've
had the Conservation Commission bought a
large portion of one one Hill because
developers kept on proposing things for
it and we'd already lost a lowincome
home uh section that was built at the
bottom of it because of the amount the
slope and the water and there is a
reason for some of these I I don't
disagree there's a there's a perfectly
valid reason for a lot of these
regulations and that's not really I'm
not questioning that I'm saying that
some of them are so restrictive that it
really raises the cost and so it's
something for the state to look
at and certainly if we're based on what
you said said if we're one of the more
restrictive in the country we need to
look at what are what are the
differences what are those restrictions
yeah um representative Stringham and
then yeah I have I have a question about
how you look at uh local property taxes
I mean our tax burden property tax
burden is about 60% of all taxes that we
raise right in the state from all
sources and uh that's very unique from
any state in the country and generally
uh you know I think the economist
perspective persective is when you tax
something you get less of it and we
generally tax property in this state uh
uniquely to any others and I wonder how
that flows through your models and your
thinking uh for
um takeaways for us yeah so I didn't
include property tax stuff in our
um if you if you were to break down the
resources or the type sources of income
right that government gets
um one of the ways that we look at it is
what sources of income what types of
Taxation are um less harmful to economic
growth um nobody likes paying property
taxes I don't like paying property taxes
um they are high in New Hampshire partly
because um our studies
on uh education funding for example show
we went through 20 years worth of data
on local education spending and State
education spending and we found that
people will just voters spend more on
their Public Schools regardless of
enrollment or regardless of anything
else they just keep pushing those
budgets up and that's driving part of
the tax um uh increase but on the
whole business taxes are quite harmful
to economic growth property taxes are
not so when you're looking at just
looking at growth which is not the only
thing to look at but just kind of one of
the ways that we look at things um if
you're going to have fund government
through some form of Taxation property
taxation is highly stable predictable
from year to year business taxation is
not as you've heard before um and it's
highly harmful to economic growth and
Innovation
so you people make trade-offs New
Hampshire has made the trade-off to Bas
a lot of its government and property
taxes that has tended to work out for us
in terms of um economic growth so but
that's one of the trade-offs that that
wer
thank thank you Mr chair I want to make
a comment about you're talking about the
growth in the 70s I was involved in that
I moved up to New Hampshire in 70 the
highways were really being built Big
Highway building thing so all of a
sudden Massachusetts was an easy commute
right and I remember being involved for
for decades with the town planning board
and and just the number of people that
realize wow I can get I can get to my
job in Boston in an hour and I can live
in New Hampshire and it's nicer I got
more room and I got lower costs and so
on so so there was a flood of people
during that period and the development
in this in the towns was abused so we
began to clamp down clamp down clamp
down through the 70s and 80s to make it
more restricted because of abuses that
happened during that period And I
remember CU I experienced it all so
that's one of the reasons we had this
huge growth and then it narrowed down
because people were getting tired of the
abuses thank you well I I would say
that's exactly what our study of um
housing restrictions found um
the local regulations that severely
restricted housing growth came often in
the 70s and 80s in response to
population growth so I that's I I won't
say whether those were abuses or not I
wasn't here then but that's how the
that's how we got where we are in terms
of regulations
yeah so
rung thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question um half of New Hampshire
residences are on private well water and
I think because local regulations for
properties homes that are on well water
have a septic tend to be very
restrictive on lot size do you think
that if there and I know in the 70s I
think there was a lot of federal money
maybe excuse me State money that went
into help municipalities build
infrastructure either Municipal Water
Systems wastewater treatment systems do
you think if that was reinstituted that
support for communities to have that
type of infrastructure it would um allow
more housing to be
built possibly I think what we found in
our study is that um
the housing restrictions typically are
response to population growth so the
um that's why communities want to
restrict is they just want to restrict
the number of new people who move into
their communities uh so they will use
and things like that as a justification
for passing the
restrictions um but I'm not sure if
you funded more sewer for example if the
state created a pool of money to fund
more sewer
construction maybe on the margins not
convinced that would actually stimulate
a lot of lot size restrictions they
exist for the purpose of um keeping
population down and uh but you know
there's a one way to get around
something like that is some of the
formulas that these communities might
use um might be out of date now so for
example I think there's a bill in the
house to do soil based zoning so it
would basically instead of having a
something written into the ordinance
that says well you can't build uh if you
have septics you can't build on a a lot
smaller than 2 Acres you would simply
have an ordinance that says um you can
your lot size has to be comminate with
what your septic system
can accommodate because we have new
higher Tech septic systems that are able
to be put on smaller Lots so that's one
way to do it okay thank you yeah
represent Malloy thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr kle for taking my question
I want to uh I missed the numbers that
you quoted from from housing
permits 70 in the 70s to the population
yeah could you go through that again
yeah just I just picked 1973 because our
numbers here stopped at 2023 so I
thought it would be a good look back um
New Hampshire's population according to
the census in 1973 was 791 th000 that
year developers received build building
permits for
4554 single family housing units and
3,179 multif family units
and then the 2023 numbers um so 1.4
million people developers receive
building permits for
2,996 single family housing units and
1,516 multif family units thank you
you're
welcome yes represented
opal uh thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you Mr Klein I appreciate you're
taking my question I I I just want to
make sure I I heard you correctly yeah
um I I believe as I looked at your your
slides you're saying that uh business
taxes or revenue from business taxes has
increased substantially in state of New
Hampshire um and you also I believe said
that that business taxes are more
harmful to economic growth than say
property taxes correct I there are some
people in my community who might
disagree with you but yeah I bet and I I
guess what I'm trying to do is reconcile
that with the fact that at least based
on what I've heard in the last two days
uh the Hampshire's economy has
apparently strong and has
outperformed not only the region but in
many cases the country um with with the
I think the lowest unemployment rate uh
in in the region so I I see where you're
going with that and and um yeah just
could you
yeah sure so I've got some I I address
that a little bit in some slides further
down um but business taxation is not
obviously the only factor in your
economy so um it's one factor in
economic growth it's not the only Factor
so we have pretty high business taxation
as a state um compared to other states
we've gone down in the last couple years
obviously but when you look at other
factors aside taxation so taxation is
one and this is another thing that b
Center tries to look at right so Live
Free or Die doesn't just mean low taxes
or die right so taxes are just one part
of what government does it's just one
cost among many costs um for businesses
for individuals so it's one factor so
all things being equal you want your
business tax rates to be low enough to
be
competitive um but you also want your
government spending to be low so
government spending also imposes a
burden on the economy and there's quite
a lot of research on developed countries
and government spending and I'm going to
get to some charts on this in just a
second um but just to preempt some of
the questions we're we are not
advocating getting rid of government
just want to make that very clear
government does a lot of essential
things um but when in the developed
world when it comes to um economic
growth there a lot of studies that we've
looked at including from the
international monetary fund and the
organization Organization for economic
cooperation and development that have
looked at countries around the world and
found um what you call an upside down U
so once um when you start basic
government provision of services that is
a boom to the economy right if you have
transportation networks if you have
communication networks if you have basic
government services courts that kind of
thing policing you're going to see an
increase in your economic growth if you
don't have those things before right but
you get to a point where there you start
to have diminishing returns and that's
the upside down curve of the U and then
if you keep growing government beyond
that again all things are being equal
you start to generally speaking see um
harm to the economic growth of that so
that's kind of where we are but I can
get to some of that in in a minute all
right let's take one more question and
then we'll move on representative Aly
thank you
um what we have got is the lowest
government
spending per something in the country as
far as I can tell certainly uh because
we have so much of our taxation is in
property
tax
there government can't had there are
things that government is extremely
efficient at and having all these small
towns have to do it themselves is not
efficient and I am pretty sure that we
have long since passed that stage we're
not in that U we're in a different you
going down the other way that that we've
got a lot of small towns that because
they no longer get services
from the state government are having to
pay for it and figure out how to do it
themselves M and some of them are better
others all right I'm going to go to to
the uh next
slide um and this gets to the size of
government uh so the Frasier Institute
which you guys are familiar with from
Taylor caswell's presentation but I'll
talk a little bit about their bigger
report in a minute they just released a
report which I thought was really
interesting this month um they looked at
New England states and the northeastern
uh provinces of Canada and and looked at
the size of government and that is
government expenditures total
expenditures for government as a
percentage of GDP for these states and
provinces and I think what you'll notice
here and represent me you are correct
New Hampshire um is at the bottom of the
list here uh 30% in 2021 so again to go
back to some economic studies that we've
looked at on that upside down you there
are different percentages some say 20% %
of GDP is where you start to see
diminishing returns and then negative
impact some say 30% so New Hampshire at
around 30% is right there at the point
where further growth of government
spending is probably going to start to
be a bit of a drag it's probably You
could argue that it is currently a drag
on the economy but um this next one I
just did just to show just went back to
2000 to 2023 just to get a a sense you
can start these in different places I
thought 20 was just a nice place to
start to look at the century um this is
New England GDP
growth um adjusted for
inflation so you can see Massachusetts
up there 61% very good their econom is
uh Strong and booming uh New Hampshire
54% second in the region um I thought it
was important to point out that Maine
and Vermont are our two Neighbors in
Northern New England are at 42% so we do
significantly better than Main and
Vermont at economic growth Rhode Island
and Connecticut
not doing so well so I want to get to
the Frasier Institute report on
um economic freedom which
is what Taylor Caswell mentioned
yesterday about one one of the few
reports that New Hampshire question
representative Mr chair May
yes one of the questions that uh came up
for me after unfortunately uh Taylor
caswell's presentation was can you
please define economic freedom because
absolutely I don't have a clu absolutely
thank you I'll be happy to do that
um so the Fraser Institute uh has been
doing this study for 20 years they've
looked at 26 years worth of data initial
study they looked back a couple more
years New Hampshire's been ranked first
in economic freedom in all of North
America 23 out of those 20 six years
that they've studied so economic freedom
uh one way to think about it is economic
autonomy it's how many economic
decisions do you as an individual get to
control versus how many of those
decisions are controlled by the state or
somebody else you know some entity of
government the way the Fraser Institute
measures this is government spending
it's three it's three portions
government level of government spending
and we saw the 30% there in New
Hampshire is how how they measure it
Taxation and then labor market Freedom
so it's regulations on your ability to
enter and participate in the labor
market and they break those down into
multiple other you can their report is
on our website jet.org if you want to
get down in much more detail but those
are the three metrics um New Hampshire
consistently ranks first or second and
those depending on Idaho or Florida and
whether they have some tax cut or uh
regular cut but most of the time New
Hampshire ranks number one in those and
a big part of the reason New Hampshire
ranks consistently number one is our
relatively low level of government
spending so that that plays a a very big
factor in New Hampshire being up there
all we have a pretty high level of
regulations on our economy surprisingly
um but our government spending and our
taxation pretty much keeps us at the top
so that's how they look at it and so
when I say that the BART Center looks at
economic freedom and we look at policies
that promote freedom and provote open
markets and a a market is a mechanism
where you make economic transactions
based on buyers and sellers coming to an
agreement on stuff government absolutely
has a role to play and enforcing
contracts and creating the regulatory
boundaries of Market but the more free
that market can
be the more mutually beneficial it is
and the more economic growth you get and
everything else follows from economic
growth right we find that economic
growth uh the the higher economic growth
you're going to have higher incomes
you're going to have higher uh levels of
well-being across the board lower levels
of poverty and we see this in New
Hampshire I mean New Hampshire has the
lowest poverty rate in the country and
it has for a very long time and just a
way to sort of contextualize this what
I'm always amazed at is that we have a
lower poverty rate than
Utah which is very culturally
conservative
it's amazing to me that New Hampshire
consistently beats Utah in poverty rate
um part of it is that we are um a very
economically free state so I just pulled
some charts from the economic freedom in
North America report which we partner
with the Frasier Institute on in terms
of publicizing and they do the report we
don't do the report but we're partners
of them um in talking about it and
getting coverage for it so this is one
of the chart they have all government
economic freedom so this is through all
of um North America Canada Mexico and
the
US income growth so you can see the
least economically fre States from 2013
to 2022 negative 13% economic growth the
third quartile 7% the second 19% the
most economically free states had 29%
economic
growth it's an indication of how
important it is to be to have economic
freedom This Is Us only taking out
Canada and Mexico economic freedom and
change in population so the least
economically free states lost
population you can see the giant
increase from negative
.8% to 8.3% in the most economically
free
states again this is United
States this is change in total
employment
least economically free states 4% to the
most economically fre free states three
times that
12% and we can see some of the effects
of this um this last chart is the Bureau
of Labor
Statistics this is changing non-farm
payrolls since January of 2020 so we're
looking back at the pandemic and you can
see New
Hampshire 3%
increase Massachusetts negative Vermont
negative Maine pretty good 2.8 but we do
better than the rest of New England
there so that's a a one of the effects
of having an overall high score on
economic freedom as you get this kind of
uh result so that's one of the reasons
why when we look at policies we're
looking at policies that create markets
and create more freedom more choices for
people because the results tend to be
quite good across the board y uh yes
representative uh Shamburg followed by
alberger thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Klein sir uh I it's a two-part
question here uh the Josiah Bartlett
Center on January 10th stated and you've
covered these here the most pressing
public policy priorities are housing
shortage which you've covered very well
uh number two is the absence of a
functioning Market in K through 12
education and state spending exceeding
projected state revenue so my first
question is
Y what is the absence what's the meaning
of the absence of functioning Market in
K through 12 education is it data driven
or is it Theory well it's both um
so if you think of the way we do K
through2 education now um versus the way
we do higher education so if you go to
college you even if you get a pel grant
so you're getting government assistance
you can purchase uh an education
anywhere in the country that you want to
um that's not the case and K through 12
so we have a we have a market in higher
education because um it's
consumer-driven consumers can choose
where to go how much they want to spend
they can go to cheaper colleges better
whatever um and they can even take
government money to do that we don't
have that in K through 12 so K through2
in New Hampshire you're assigned to a
public school if you want to go to a
different school um and can't afford it
well you're stuck if you if there's not
a charter school near you maybe there's
a public charter school which would be
great um we see uh studies in the last
couple years from um academic
institutions and even one from uh which
came out this fall which I would
encourage everybody to go to from uh the
progressive policy Institute which is
not a free market they're they're
Progressive Think Tank they don't like
education savings accounts um so they're
against those but they so but they do
like charter schools and they did a
study of charter schools and the
penetration into a local District of um
charter schools so they found that once
a charter school enrollment in a in any
Public School District reaches about 30%
you see a dramatic increase in test
score performance in the kids in the
district public
school so when we say a functioning
Market in K through2 education what we
mean is consumers parents can choose
which school to go to whether that's
through efas preferably um which are
very expansive um you can also do it in
a couple of different bills that are
working their way in the legislature now
there's one that would in two in the
Senate both of them would give um open
enrollment for your public school
district um one is open enrollment
within your District which which help
somewhat but the other is open
enrollment across the board so you could
go to any public school in the state
again that would help to create a market
so you could shop around we have 29
highquality studies done on the effects
of school choice on school districts
when school
choice enters a district and parents
actually have the option to take their
Public School dollars and and go
purchase an education on the market of
those 29 studies 26 find a positive
effect on outcomes for students who
remain in the public
schools and so that's what we mean by
creating a market when you have that
market
competition it's about improving the
outcomes for
everybody so okay that's one of the
priorities that we're looking at for the
legislature if we get to the point where
this year say they pass um Universal
school choice of some form we would
expect to see some pretty substantial
economic positive impact from that okay
on the follow-up question Mr chairman
the uh second thing when you spending
exceeding projected State now way and
means is a very moderate
group in looking at sources of revenue
from the 14 categories of state revenue
and recommending it
forward my question is
can you speculate on how the state
spends more Revenue than what way and
means reports out to the next
committee I'm sorry I don't quite
get since we're the ones Ways and Means
is looking at our
sources and it's more of a crystal ball
approach I think and then we do it twice
we only we don't do it once we do it
twice we recommend out it still seems to
gets out of here and it just shoots up
even though we are more in the center of
what we're trying to develop I think I
see what you're saying are you are you
asking how do the general the
legislature as a whole increase revenues
right just want to know uh just a theory
that's a theory isn't it no yeah I think
I I think I might leave that to you I
don't I don't know if I'd want to
speculate that one sure thank you um
representative
elberger thank you Mr chair I actually
have two questions sure the first one uh
related to something that you just
mentioned uh you mentioned that New
Hampshire's poverty late poverty rate is
quite low lower even than Utah y uh at
the same time New Hampshire's increase
in the homeless population is the
highest in the
country so I'm trying trying to figure
out how you reconcile that with a sense
of economic us having more economic
freedom than anyone else when we have
had this enormous increase in the
homeless population um so I haven't
tried to study the increase in the
homeless population myself and we at
Barlett haven't looked at who those
individuals are whether they've moved
into the New Hampshire from out of state
any of that so we don't I don't want to
necessarily I don't have independent
numbers on what that population is um so
at this point I don't think we know from
our point from our institution if that
increase in the homeless population was
people who migrated here in the last
year versus people who may have become
native New Hampshire people who became
homeless um one study I have looked at
was done by the Manhattan Institute and
just published in the last couple of
weeks where they looked at the last year
huge increases in the homeless
population all around the country
and they attributed the majority of that
increase to Illegal immigration so
that's from a national level I think
that's one of the places to sort of look
and see um how did that overlap with New
Hampshire but I don't have that data to
know exactly who those people are just a
followup to that first question let's
take out any immigrants and just look at
however many homeless people we have
here okay how do we reconcile that
significant homeless population with the
notion of economic
freedom um I'm not sure I quite
understand what the point you're getting
at uh we have a safety net in New
Hampshire we have safety nets in local
communities um we have policies that are
not conducive to helping people find
places to live and I think think we've
written a bit about that in the past
about housing policies that could be
more open to allow to to find helping
people find homes and lowcost homes you
know one of the problems that we've seen
in New Hampshire is that the growth of
these local regulations for example have
essentially baned boarding houses in
many many many communities in in in the
state so there are very few places where
you can have um what we used to have in
the 19th and most of the 20th century
the first half of the 20th century which
is a boarding house where you can charge
very low rates at a weekly basis or a
monthly basis those boarding houses that
used to be very common um essentially no
longer exist because of housing policy
so that's is one factor but there's also
um mental health Investments and all
kinds of other things that contribute to
that population
but the existence of a population of
people who are struggling to get by does
not negate the
um
on the state of having a largely free
economy that what we've seen again to
point out the data and you can go to an
or a website called our world and data
where they point out that how economic
growth has essentially
eradicated um extreme poverty it's not
entirely gone but because of economic
growth and it's almost been wiped out
and so it's better to have more freedom
and more economic growth which creates
the wealth that we then use to provide
Social Services to
people um I
will suggest you might talk to some of
those folks who are struggling but as a
separate question you also mentioned
some studies
concerning uh choice in in a general
term yeah with regard to education and
you talked about data that was
collected concerning people satisfaction
and the rise in test scores among
different
populations the way the education
Freedom accounts are set up here in New
Hampshire there is no accountability we
don't know what costs are we have no
idea what testing is well we know what
we're paying in we don't know where that
all that money is going necessarily
respectfully man that's incorrect U the
children's scholarship fund literally
vets every single purchase down to the
penny so we have reports on that we know
exactly where that money goes we know
precisely what that money is spent on
they produce reports on that and um we
in fact are the most uh
heavily put it this way New Hampshire
vets the spending more aggressively than
every other every other education
savings account in the country I've had
um folks from other
states um ask why in the world do you
guys vet every expenditure you make us
look bad because we don't do that every
single expenditure gets vetted you
cannot um go for example so Amazon is a
vendor in the education Freedom account
program if you put um your
approved educational items in your a
cart from Amazon and then throw a bag of
Oreos in that entire cart will not get
approved the system doesn't allow that
um that's how that's the level of degree
of oversight that we have on the
spending M we um I'm going to have to
cut it off there we've got we're over
time I've got I'm going to call on two
more people representative ORS and
representative rung and then we'll end
to be respectful of the time
representative ORS thank you Mr chair
and thanks again for taking my question
sure uh it's one thing about the
homeless I saw a documentary that most
of the homeless are homeless because of
their drug addiction so I'm not sure but
I just wanted to mention that my
question is uh what is you talked about
the business business tax rate and
healthy economics what is the mass tax
rate for business versus New Hampshire
um mass is actually better than us I
don't I would call right off hand 7 and
a half% four four yeah I think it's
that's why I thought was about 4 it's so
they're but they're trade-off right
so we don't tax personal income and they
do right so they've or sales right so
they balance it so they can have a lower
business tax rate because they have
broad-based taxes which which we don't
have so that's why our business tax rate
is is higher so it's approximately four
versus 7 and a half or something like
that I I'll take your four yeah very
run thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question sure regarding the K
through2 education Market um Do You
Believe parents have as much control
over the quality of their schools um
by just electing Schoolboard members
don't school boards who are elected by
all voters in the community have the
power to develop education and curricula
to meet the needs of the students no
thank you for the question that's
actually a great question um and I I
think the answer is no and the reason is
um when you have a school district to
which all students in that District are
assigned and they must go um if they
want to access their public education
money you have a 50% plus one on the
school board right so the board is voted
on by the entire Community right it
makes decisions for the entire community
and it's a 50 plus one so 50% plus one
gets to pass the policy so if you're in
the
49% that might disagree with that policy
you have nowhere to go right so if you
have for example um you can take any
number of curricula issues Library
access um the way special ed is offered
like any number of things that might
impact the way you uh interact with your
education as a child if the collective
decision to offer a public education in
that school in this particular way
doesn't work for you and your child
doesn't respond well to that you're
stuck there whereas if you have the
ability to shop around and the education
Freedom accounts include other District
Public Schools I think that's very clear
and that was by Design you can go buy a
private education but you can also take
that and go to another District public
school if you want if you find one that
works better for you that creates more
accountability uh for the parent for the
school district and it allows people to
match their educational needs much more
closely with providers out there in the
market so it works as state government
right a majority plus one yeah thank
sure all right thank thank you thank you
helpful okay that concludes today's
program and
um watch your watch your email for uh
next week we will be
meeting um on um was Fant Tuesday the
21st and Wednesday the 22nd uh both
times start times 10 o'clock um the
agenda will be coming out in the
calendar if uh we're still having some
discussion here so if you take your
hello Tuesday and Wednesday 10
o'clock okay any qu does anyone have any
questions in the on the
committee seeing none thank you very
trouble